ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS HAVE BEEN PULLED AB ONE
THIRTY EIGHT AB EIGHT FIFTY A.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE AND AB.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY TWO STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE STILL
HERE [inaudible]
NEWSELA.
RIGHT MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOR MR COOLEY WHICH YOU LIKE AND
AND WE'RE STARTING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
VERY GOOD -- MADAM CHAIR.
I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY 2%
A. B. TWO NINETY SIX SHARE THIS
HOUSE BY MICE -- AUTHOR THIS
HOUSE BY MYSELF WITH HER
DAUGHTER EDUARDO GARCIA.
AND SOONER STERN IN THE OTHER
HOUSE.
OF THIS MEASURE WILL ESTABLISH
THE CLIMATE.
INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
IT AIMS TO PROVIDE.
FUNDING FOR AN ARRAY OF TOOLS TO
HELP US TO A CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUES.
THE PEACE A BRINGS US HERE IS IT
HAS IT DOES NOT REPLY RELY UPON
EPIC FUNDS OR SIMILAR FUNDS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY.
DEDICATED WITH A PURPOSE.
IT IS SIX FOUR PRIVATE FUNDS
OTHER PUBLIC MONIES TO BE BE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IN A TWO STATE TAX CHECKOFF
PIECE TO ALLOW PEOPLE. TO
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR THIS. TO
OPEN UP.
INVESTMENT IN STRATEGIES CAN
HELP US TO CLIMATE CHANGE ON A
BROAD ARRAY OF SUBJECTS OVERSEEN
BY THE ARE.
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL SO THE
BILL REPRESENTS INNOVATION.
IT REPRESENTS AN INVESTMENT IN
TRYING TO RELEASE ENERGY ON THE
CLIMATE CHALLENGES.
AND I AM PLEASED TODAY TO HAVE --
MERRY SELECT KEY.
OF SPEAKING I'M IN SUPPORT OF
ALSO MISTER TURNED HER TO GET
THINGS ROLLING.
HELLO MY NAME IS MERRY SELECTING
I JOIN YOU TODAY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE LARGE TO
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF AB T..
NINETY SIX MARTA IS A LOS
ANGELES BASED NGO THAT
TRANSFORMS IDEAS AND RESEARCH
INTO MARKET READY PRODUCTS.
SINCE LARGEST FOUNDING IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE IT HAS
BEEN A COMMERCIALIZATION PARTNER
TO TOP FEDERAL AGENCIES.
AND HAS ASSISTED OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
BRINGING THEIR RESEARCH TO
MARKET.
THIRTIES WORKERS ON A NATIONAL
SCALE BUT HAS PROFOUND IMPACTS
ON THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
LIKE TO SUPPORT OF AB TWO NINETY
SIX BECAUSE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WE SEE THE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
DOLLARS INVESTED IN RESEARCH
YIELDS POSITIVE ECONOMIC
OUTCOMES.
WE RECOGNIZE THE BILL AUTHORS
INTENTIONS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE BY ALLOCATING RESOURCES
FOR CLIMATE RELATED RESEARCH.
CLEARLY EXCITED TO BE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICES ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRIDGE THE GAP
FROM RESEARCH TO MARKET READY
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE CLIMATE
INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM WOULD
NOT ONLY ADVANCE CALIFORNIA'S
CLIENT GOALS BUT WILL BRING
POSITIVE ECONOMIC GROWTH TO THE
STATE. TO FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENTS
THAT PARALLEL ARTISTS CORE
MISSION.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM UTILIZES THE
SUCCESSFUL MODEL THAT WE SEE
ELSEWHERE IN THE UNITED STATES
WHICH IS LEVERAGING MATCHING
FUNDS AND THUS COMBINING MANY
FUNDING SOURCES FOR APPLIED
RESEARCH.
WITH THE HELP OF FEDERAL AND
STATE FUNDING PROGRAMS AND
ACCELERATORS SUCH AS LARGE HER
COME COMPANIES LIKE MANGO
MATERIALS CAN TURN THE RESEARCH
INTO MARKET READY PRODUCTS
MINGLE MATERIALS BASED IN
BERKELEY PRODUCES A BIOPOLYMER
RECYCLED METHANE AND CREATES
BIOPLASTICS.
MEGA MATERIALS TO START BY THREE
WOMEN ENGINEERS AND WAS AWARDED
RESEARCH FUNDING BUT UTILIZE
THEIR TO SERVICES TO HELP PROPEL
THEIR PRODUCT INTO THE MARKET.
LARGE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SIMILAR SERVICES FOR
ANY STATE FUNDED RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AND WE ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB.
TWO NINETY SIX AND I ALSO WISH
TO THANK OF THE COMMITTEE ROSE
MARIE FOR PERSISTENCE ON
AMENDMENTS.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT.
I ACCEPT THOSE OFFERS AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS IN
COMMITTEE.
I THINK THE OTHER FOR BRINGING
THIS FOR JUST OVER THE BREAK
WITH A DENTAL BUT A TRAVEL --
AND WAS OVER IN IN EUROPE SEEING --
WHAT SEEMS TO BE THE FIRST
TECHNOLOGY THAT ACTUALLY TAKES
CARBON DIRECTLY OUT OF -- OF THE
YEAR I WAS JUST FASCINATING TO
BE ABLE TO TO SEE COURSE AS YOU
START TO DIG INTO IT A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
YOU YOU UNDERSTAND THAT EACH ONE
OF THESE MACHINES THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED -- WOULD WE WOULD NEED
SOMETHING LIKE EIGHTY MILLION OF
THEM.
PER YEAR OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS --
IF YOU DO THE MATH ON THAT BE
PRETTY PRETTY DIFFICULT MY POINT
IS IS THAT THERE IS INNOVATION
THAT IS -- THAT IS AT ITS THAT
IS STARTING AND WE BOTH GOT TO
FIGURE OUT -- WE'VE GOT
INCENTIVIZE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE BEEN A LEADER -- IN IN
WITH CAP AND TRADE IN AB THIRTY
TWO AND SB THIRTY TWO AND MAYBE
THREE NINETY EIGHT BUT THAT'S
NOT GONNA BE ENOUGH TO BUILD A
REDUCE -- OUR OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SO ANYWAY THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE OUR LEADERSHIP ROLE --
I WILL I WELCOME THAT SORT OF
THANK YOU FOR A FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND DIDN'T KNOW IF
YOU HAD ANY ANY COMMENTS OR ANY
THOUGHTS ON SOME GRANDIOSE IDEAS
I'M SURE -- EIGHT OF COURSE YOU
ALWAYS DO WELL ACTUALLY --
COLLEAGUE YOU KNOW ALL THE GOOD
THINGS WE LEARNED WE LEARNED AND
PRESCHOOL.
SO I JUST FOR SITE YOU KNOW THE
THE POEM. FOR WANT OF A NAIL THE
SHOE WAS LOSS. FOR ONE OF THE
NAIL. FOR FOR FOR THE NAIL SHE
WAS LOST FOR WANT OF A SHOE THE
HORSE WAS LOST FOR THE HORSE
RIDERS LOSS FOR ONE OF THE RIGHT
OF THE BATTLE WAS LOST. FOR ONE
OF THE BALLOT CAME IT WAS LOST
AND ALL FOR THE WANT OF A NAIL.
I THINK WE IN CALIFORNIA. TO
NEED TO BE WORRIED.
ABOUT THE VERY GOOD IDEAS.
THAT WERE NOT ALLOWED TO TAKE
ROOT.
IF SOMEONE DIDN'T BELIEVE
STUDENTS TO CLAMOR POSSIBILITY.
TO GET SOMEBODY TO INVEST IN
THAT IDEAS WERE COULD BECOME
SOMETHING GREATER.
I THINK THAT IS THE REAL
CHALLENGE OF LEADERSHIP IN THIS
ROUND.
AND I DO AGREE WITH YOU THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS EXERTED GREAT
LEADERSHIP.
AND I THINK THIS BILL FITS INTO
THAT.
AND REALLY REPRESENTS THE PEACE
IN THIS COMMITTEE IT OFFERS AN
INVITATION TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
TO SHARE IN THAT. TO MAKE THAT
LITTLE DIFFERENCE THAT ACTUALLY
GROWS INTO SOMETHING SO MUCH
MORE CONSEQUENTIAL.
SOUL -- I WILL SAY I AM NOT THE
ONE WITH THE GRANDIOSE IDEAS.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO BE THE ONE
THAT WAS HELD THE NAY HILL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
TO THE COMMITTEE SEEING NINE
WHICH WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE I THINK OF
THE OPPORTUNITY JOIN YOU.
ON THIS EARTH DAY.
AND AS A DAY TO A MOVE FOR THE
NORTH PAGE AND I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT -- AB TWO NINE SIX TWO
YOU THINK YOU ARE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
PARTNER MIKE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
CLICK IF YOU'LL CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible] TO WE ARE
[inaudible]
GRAY MANSE [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE NORRIS.
QUIRK YEAR REAVIS TING.
WELL WE ARE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR AUTHORS [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE MOVIE YEAH [inaudible]
SECOND.
THE TIME IN COLORADO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
BURKE [inaudible]
AS AMENDED [inaudible]
BURKE HI.
BURKE I ROLE.
REAL AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY MAYES.
MAYES AYE MELINDA'S.
MULLIN PATCHING ORDERS. THREE
NORTH AYE AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE REAVIS TING.
THE BILL IS.
SIX ZERO BILLS OUT.
SIX TWO ZERO NOW WE'RE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS
[inaudible]
THIS.
I WELL RATING WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO THE VOTE ONLY ITEM
STARTING THE FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
A. B. [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE THE BILL [inaudible]
THEN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE RIGHT BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO RHU CHEW ON A GRAY MAYES.
MAYES ARI MELINDA THIS MULLIN.
THREE NORRIS BETWEEN NORTH AYE
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE REAVIS KING.
THAT BILLS OUT.
LIVING A FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
TWO ELEVEN TO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
THE SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WAS HIGHLY CHOLERA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE HI BURKE AYE ROW.
ROW RHU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES I WANT IS MULLIN PETRIE
NORRIS.
PUT YOUR NORRIS AYE AYE QUIRK.
WORK NO REAVIS TING CAPITALISM
CALL.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL
[inaudible]
THE HIGHLANDS.
LIVING FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB
FOUR SIXTEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION. TO HAVE A SECOND.
AND THE SECOND.
WITH HIGHLY YOU CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
BROUGHT UP BURKE AYE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO.
BRO I TO CHIU I'D GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES I'M MELINDA IS ROLAND.
PETRIE NORRIS PENSIONERS I'D
QUIRK NO WORK NO REAVIS TING THE
BILL IS ON CALL.
DOUBLES ON CALL.
WILLIAM FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
FIVE THIRTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION. TO HAVE A SECOND.
SECOND I THINK YOUR IS HIGHLY
COLORADO MAYES.
MAYES II MELINDA'S [inaudible]
ROLAND.
PETRIE NORRIS.
BUT YOUR NORRIS I'D QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE REAVIS TING
[inaudible]
DOUBLES OUT.
THAT BILL IS OUT -- IN A FILE
ITEM NINETEEN AB FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND IN MOTION --
MADAM CHAIR CAN ASK A QUESTION.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE BILL HAS
TAKEN AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL MAKE
IT.
ARE POSSIBLE FOR F. T. BE.
TO ADMINISTER IT THE ANALYSIS
TALKS ABOUT THAT IS THAT TRUE
THAT IT'S TAKEN AMENDMENTS.
DOZEN MEMBERS HAVEN'T BEEN
TAKING AND IF THEY'RE TAKEN TO
BE TAKEN APPROPRIATIONS ARE THEY
GOING TO BE TAKEN.
OUR UNDERSTANDING YEAH IT'S ME
ASKING WILL BE TAKEN IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SHE IS GOING
TO TAKE THEM YES OKAY THAT'S
GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME THANK YOU.
BECAUSE OF THAT THEY WILL BE
TAKEN ALL RIGHT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO.
RONO CHIU.
SURE OUR GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING MELENDEZ.
MULLIN PETRIE NORRIS.
BETWEEN NORTH AYE QUIRK MIGHT
WORK I READ THIS KING.
PHONE CALL NEEDS.
TO THAT I AM IS ON CALL IT NEEDS.
TO WE HAVE AN AUTHOR.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM [inaudible]
MISSION ON BY -- HERE WHOSE
FIRST TO RUN TO FIRST.
WE WILL FILE ITEM THREE AB.
ONE SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I THINK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
TODAY ON AB ONE SEVENTY SIX IN
DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE LA -- RELEASES STATE
MANDATED REPORT ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY ADVANCE
TRANSPORTATION FINANCE
AUTHORITIES SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPT.
EXCLUSION PROGRAM TO ME ITS
STATUTORY MISSION GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE ALLEY OWES
RECOMMENDATIONS AB ONE SEVENTY
SIX REQUIRES A CASE FOR TO
FORMALLY RESPOND TO THE FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE LA --
REPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
IN THE COMMITTEE DOT QUIRK --
IT'S WHY DO WE NEED A BILL. TO
GET ON THE OUT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE OPPOSED TO TALK ABOUT IT --
I WOULD THINK THAT THEY COULD
TALK ANYWAY.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
AUTHORITY TO REFUTE THE CLAIMS --
AND RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY THE
ALEJO.
BUT THEY COULD DO THAT WITHOUT A
BILL I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHY WE
HAVE A BILL.
THIS IS THE PATH FOR THAT WE SAW
BASS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THAT THANK YOU -- TO SPEAK TO
THAT ROOM AS ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
ROGERS AND I HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE BEST WAY
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS ITEM
AND THIS IS WHERE WE LANDED.
OKAY WE WILL WE WILL I THINK THE
GOAL IS TO HAVE SOME HEARINGS
OVER THE FALL FURTHER DISCUSS
WHAT THAT REPORT LOOKS LIKE AND
WHAT THE BEST WAY. TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS ACTION ITEM AND
WILL BE.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE --
IS HIGHLY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO.
BRO ARE YOU CHU.
CHU I'D GRAY MAYES.
MAYES ARM MELINDA'S MOLEN.
PERJURY NORRIS.
NORRIS I'D QUIRK.
I WORK I READ THIS CHIANG
[inaudible]
BILLS.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIVE AB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MERRIN SYRIAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- WHICH
ONE SHOULD I START WITH
[inaudible]
THREE THREE FIFTY SEVEN PERFECT.
MANAGER IN PRESENTING AB THREE
FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS A TECHNICAL
BILL DEALING WITH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD AND THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS.
OF TWENTY YEARS FOR THE FTP TO
COLLECT ON AN OUTSTANDING TAX
LIABILITY MOVE THE BELL.
THIS CODE THANK YOU THIS CODE
SECTION ALSO INCLUDES FEES ARE
LEANS ASSOCIATED WITH AN
ORIGINAL TAX LIABILITY THE FTV
INTERPRETS CURRENT CODE TO MEAN
THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS
ESSENTIALLY RESETS.
STATUE OF LIABILITY AND
COLLECTIONS STATUTE ON THE
TOTALITY OF THE INITIAL THAT
WHEN THEY ASSESS NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE AND COLLECTION
FEES -- I WILL CUT SHORT MY
PRESENTATION AND GO TO JOSEPH
BRACE -- TAX ATTORNEY FROM LOS
ANGELES TO FURTHER EXPLAIN YOU
SURE ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M JUST BOILS LOS ANGELES I'M A
TAX FREE AND CPA I STARTED MY
CAREER AT THE IRS TWENTY NINE
YEARS AGO AND WORK FOR THE IRISH
FOR NINE YEARS.
IN THE FEDERAL SYSTEM THERE IS A
TEN YEAR STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
THAT BEGINS ON THE DATE OF
ASSESSMENT AND EACH ASSESSMENT
HAS A TEN YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX CALIFORNIA
PASSED A TWENTY YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS BUT MECHANICS ARE
DIFFERENT THE CALIFORNIA STATUTE
IMITATIONS APPLIES TO EACH TAX
PERIOD.
NOT TO EACH ASSESSMENT AND WITH
WITHIN EACH TAX PUREE WHENEVER
THERE'S A NEW ASSESSMENT THE
TWENTY YEAR PERIOD.
SMALL RESTARTS.
UP.
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS THAT
THE FTP CHARGES MANY MANY FEES
ANDCOSTS THAT RESTART UNDER THE
CURRENT STATUTE THESE FEES AND
COSTS TO RESTART THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
THE FTP FILES A LEADING THE
CHARGE OF SIXTEEN TO EIGHTEEN
DOLLAR FEE THAT FECAL RESTARTS
THE TWENTY YEAR CLOCK.
IF A TAXPAYER ONCE INSTALLMENT
AGREEMENT THE FTP CHARGES THE
THIRTY FOUR DOLLAR FEE FOR THAT
STONE.
THAT WE START TO THE STATUE
MEDICATIONS I DON'T THINK IT WAS
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT TO
ALLOW THE THE FTP TO
UNILATERALLY RESTART THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS.
EVERY TIME THE FTP CHARGES A FEE
YOUR COST.
THIS.
THE STATUTE CORRECTS.
THE EXISTING LAWS SO THAT FEES
AND COSTS DON'T RESTART THE
STATUE LIMITATIONS ONLY THE
ASSESSMENT.
OF ADDITIONAL TAX RESTART TO SET
YOU MEDICATIONS.
AND I I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JUST THE FACTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
SIDE OF CERTIFIED PUBLIC
ACCOUNTANTS IN WORDS STRONG
SUPPORT I WILL LEAVE THIS IS
MEASURE ADDRESSES A PRACTICAL
TAX APPLICATION ISSUE BY
CLARIFYING CURRENT LAW.
RELATED TO STATURE LIMITATIONS
FOR TAX ABILITY AND STRIKES A
NARAL BALANCE OF PROVIDING THE
CERTAINTY FOR TAX -- PAIRS WHILE
MEETING THE F. T. V.'S ABILITY
TO STILL COLLECT TAXES OWED.
SO WE THANK THE AUTHOR AND
MISTER BOILS FOR BEING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I'M A GREAT SUPPORTER STATUTES
OF LIMITATION AND TWENTY YEARS
IS PLENTY LONG [inaudible]
AGREED [inaudible]
AGREED -- THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU.
I WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE I FOR ARE
YOU BRO.
ROLL ON EACH YOU.
CHIU AYE GRAY MAYES.
MAYES I MULLIN THIS.
ONE COUNTRY NORRIS THE TRAINERS
AYE AYE QUIRK I WORK ON A
REVISTA HANG.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THE SIX OF AB [inaudible]
FIVE SEVENTY SIX OKAY.
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS BILL IN CONJUNCTION WITH
ACA TO WILL ELIMINATE THE FINAL
REDUNDANCIES OF HAVING MULTIPLE
TAX ENTITIES AND ASSIGN THE LAST
OF THE BE -- EASE OPERATIONS TO
THE RELEVANT EXISTING STATE
AGENCIES.
AS THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
INFORMED I HAVE BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH MULTIPLE TAX AGENCIES AND
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED AGENCIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THIS ISSUE
RIGHT.
ALL THE OFFICES INCLUDE THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
TREASURES OFFICE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD OFFICE OF TAX APPEALS
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION FEE
ADMINISTRATION -- IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PERFORMED AN EVALUATION OF THE
B. O. E..
AND IT'S PROGRAMS.
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FINANCE DEPARTMENT
RELEASED ITS REPORT WHICH FOUND
UNDER THE BE -- EASE THEN
CURRENT STRUCTURE BOARD MEMBERS
WERE ADMINISTRATORS ARBITERS AND
ADVOCATES.
FINANCE FOUND THAT THE
OPERATIONAL CULTURE WITHIN THE
B. O. E. IMPACTED ITS ABILITY TO
EVEN REPORT ACCURATE INFORMATION.
THE DECISION MAKERS OUTSIDE THE
BOP.
FOLLOWING THE RESULTS FROM THE
INVESTIGATION CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED
AB ONE OH TWO IN JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AB WANTED
TO STRIP THE B. O. E. OF NEARLY
ALL TAX ADMINISTRATION AN APPEAL
FUNCTIONS.
AND GAVE THE RESPONSIBILITIES TO
TWO NEW TAX DEPARTMENTS CDT CD
FTA.
AND THE TA.
AFTER AB ONE OH TWO PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN B. O. E.
DRASTICALLY REDUCE STAFF AND
ONLY RETAIN FOUR HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES WITH FORTY EIGHT
HUNDRED WORKERS SHIFTED TO THE
NEW DEPARTMENTS.
AGAIN THIS BILL WHICH
STATUTORILY A SIGN THE LAST OF
THE BE -- EASE OPERATIONS TO THE
RELEVANT EXISTING STATE AGENCIES
AND IS A COMPANION BILL TO A CA --
TO WHICH WILL ELIMINATE THE BOP.
A WITH ME I HAVE EVAN I'M JOINED
BY EVAN GOLDBERG FROM --
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE BEFORE
BEFORE WE DO OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WERE SUPER CLEAR WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AB THIS
BILL AB FIFTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX
IT SIMPLY SETS FOR IT WHAT THE
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK WOULD BE.
IN THE EVENT THAT A CA TO WAS
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
VOTED ON BY OUR CONSTITUENTS SO
THIS IS SIMPLY A FRAMEWORK THAT
WE ARE VOTING ON TODAY WE ARE
NOT VOTING ON THE CA I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE CLEAR
ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS EVAN
GOLDBERG WITH STATE COMPTROLLER
BETTY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
IN SUPPORT OF ACA TO IF AND WHEN
IT COMES BEFORE YOU I WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
HIS WORK ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL TIME IN THAT REQUEST
HAS BEEN GRANTED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING HOW GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MELINA
CO AND I'M CHAIR OF THE STATE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING US A FEW EXTRA MINUTES
TO MAKE A PRESENTATION TO YOU.
AB FIVE SEVEN SIX IS NOTHING
NOTHING LESS THAN AN INSTRUMENT
TO TERMINATE THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION BOTH AS AN ELECTED
BODY AND AS AN AGENCY.
THIS BILL IS MORE THAN JUST
IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION IF THE
VOTERS PASS A CA.
TO AS A MATTER OF FACT THIS BILL
IS A STATEMENT OF WHETHER YOU
CONSIDER REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT BY ELECTED
AND ACCOUNTABLE.
OFFICIALS TO BE AN IMPORTANT
THING.
IT IS A FAIR QUESTION AND HERE
IS MY ANSWER TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION IS ONE OF THE
CORE FOUNDATIONS OF OUR SYSTEMS
GOVERNMENT.
AND AS AN ELECTED BOARD WORKING
WITH A HIGHLY SKILLED BE A WE
AGENCY STAFF WE ARE CUT
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT SHOULD NOT
BE SENT OFF TO AN UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS IN THE STATE AGENCY.
BEFORE VOTING TO TERMINATE THE
BE A WE WERE URGE THAT YOU
CAREFULLY CONSIDER A FEW THINGS
FIRST THE VALUEOF TAXATION WITH
REPRESENTATION FOR CALIFORNIANS
REGARDING OUR SIXTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR PROPERTY TAX
SYSTEM.
THIS IS STILL A CORE FUNCTION
THAT RESTS WITHIN THE E. AT THE
BE A WEEK.
WHETHER IT IS REASONABLE AND
PRUDENT TO THOROUGHLY EVALUATE
THE IMPACTS OF AB ONE OH TWO AND
CREATING CD TFA AND T. A..
B. FOR PROPOSING ANY FURTHER
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE TAX
ADMINISTRATION AND CALIFORNIA
AND THIRD AND FINAL WHETHER IT
IS REASONABLE AND PRUDENT TO
CONDUCT AN IN DEPTH ANALYSIS OF
THE IMPACTS ON TAXPAYER RIGHTS.
IN TERMINATING THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION ASKING AND
ANSWERING THE QUESTION IS THERE
A BETTER WAY FORWARD.
WE ORGANIZE IN STATE GOVERNMENT
AND ENDING A ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY YEAR PRESIDENT OF TAXATION
WITH REPRESENTATION.
DESERVES TO BE.
MORE THAN SIMPLY CREATING A NEW
ORGANIZATION CHART AND HOPING
FOR THE BEST WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU VOTE NO ON AB FIVE
SEVEN SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRENDA
FLEMING I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION ON BEHALF OF TO BE
WE EMPLOYEES AND FOR THE
UTILIZATION DISTRICT MEMBERS --
FIVE WE ON BEHALF OF THE AGENCY
DO OPPOSE AB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
FIRST BILL YEARS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADMINISTERING THE STATE'S SIXTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
PROPERTY TAXES -- WHICH INCLUDES
THE ASSESSMENT OF OVER FIVE
POINT SEVEN TRILLION IN PROPERTY
TAX BY THE FIFTY EIGHT ELECTED I
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S.
THE UNIQUE NEEDS AND ISSUES OF
THE PROPERTY TAX PROGRAMS SHOULD
NOT BECOME SECONDARY TO THOSE UP
TO THE TAX OTHER TAX PROGRAMS.
MOVING THE BE -- WE'D BE ALWAYS
DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES TO
THE CD TESFAYE OR TO THE TA WHAT
ACTUALLY WEEKEND OUR ABILITY TO
REALLY DEDICATE OUR PROPERTY TAX
RESOURCES THE EMPLOYEES. TO
EXCLUSIVELY FOCUS ON PROPERTY
TAX FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE WOOD FOR
WITH -- CITY TO HAVE A BEFORE
AND AND THE PROPERTY TAX
PROGRAMS A SORT OF A SUBDIVISION --
AND SUBORDINATE TO THAT ROLE.
ANY DECISION MEMBERS TO MOVE
THIS CRITICAL STATE SERVICE --
OUR PROPERTY TAX PROGRAMS INTO
TWO OTHER STATE AGENCY SHOULD BE
THOROUGHLY ANALYZED STUDIED AND
EVALUATED. TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS FOR TAXPAYERS AND FOR
THE STATE.
SECOND MEMBERS AB ONE OH TWO
RESULTED IN ONE OF THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLEX
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES IN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND STATE AGENCIES.
IN RECENT TIMES THE TWO WEEK
TIME FRAME FROM JUNE FIFTEENTH
TO JULY TWO JULY ONE WHEN IT
TOOK AFFECT -- HAD A CATACLYSMIC
IMPACT ON THE EMPLOYEES OF THE
BE -- EITHER FOR BE WE WANT OUT
ALL.
THE PACE OF THE TRANSITION TASK
FOLLOWING THE BILL'S PASSAGE DID
NOT PROVIDE FOR THOROUGH
DECISION MAKING PROCESS THAT
ALLOW FOR THOUGHTFUL REVIEW AND
THE EVALUATION OF THE CHANGES IT
LITERALLY TOOK AFFECT PASSED AND
TOOK EFFECT IN TWO WEEKS.
AS A RESULT A STATE GOVERNMENT
AGENCY HAS BEEN LEFT WITH AN
ADEQUATE AND INEFFICIENT
AUTHORITIES.
RESOURCES AND CAPABILITIES TO
FULFILL ITS MANDATE ITS STATE
GOVERNMENT DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
WE DEFINITELY ARE WEEKEND AS A
RESULT OF IT.
THIRD MEMBERS ALLEGED BOARD IS
ESSENTIAL TO THE B. ALWAYS
ABILITIES FOR TO FULFILL ITS
DUTIES.
UNFORTUNATELY ARE ULTIMATELY FOR
OVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY YEARS
THE ELECTED BOARD HAS
DEMONSTRATED RESPONSIVENESS JUST
HAVE TO STAKEHOLDERS AS A PART
OF THE ELECT TOWARD A COMPARED
TO AN APPOINTED AGENCY
ADMINISTRATOR. FOR THE IMPACT OF
ANY DECISION YOU MAKE TODAY
RELATED TO THE ADMINISTRATION OF
PROPERTY TAXES MUST THOUGHTFULLY
CONSIDER THE IMPACT ON OUR
EMPLOYEES.
THE ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER FROM AB ONE
OUT TO OUR CURRENT LITERALLY
OVERNIGHT ON JUNE THIRTIETH WE
RUBIO WE WANT OUT ALL AND ON
JULY ONE WE WERE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATION.
STRIPPED WITH THE MAJORITY OF
OUR RESOURCES -- IT HAPPENED
OVERNIGHT AND THE STAFF HAD
GREAT DIFFICULTY ABSORBING THE
MAGNITUDE OF THAT IMPACT.
AND LASTLY MEMBERS IF I COULD
JUST COMMENT WE CANNOT FAIL TO
PROTECT THE DUTY -- RB WE DUTY
TO PROTECT AND ENSURE OUR
ABILITY TO APPLY -- AND SO THE
UNIFORMITY OF OUR OUR STATE
TAXES AND REALLY FULFILL OUR OUR
OUR MISSION -- AS YOU HEARD
BEFORE THE COUNTY PROPERTY TAX
LEVIES THAT TOTAL OVER SIXTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OUR COUNTY IS
SAYS PROPERTY VALUES REACH FIVE
POINT SEVEN TRILLION.
THE STATUS AS PROPERTIES VALUED
HUNDRED FIVE POINT FOUR FIVE
BILLION ECCENTRIC CETERA AGAIN
OUR APPEAL HONORABLE MEMBERS IS
TO ALLOW MORE TIME FOR
THOUGHTFUL PROCESS -- THAT
MINIMIZES THE IMPACT ON THE
EMPLOYEES AND ALLOWS US TO
EXCESS TO SUCCESSFULLY
ADMINISTER ARE ON PROPERTY TAX
FUNCTIONS.
AGAIN WE OPPOSE IT -- WITH AFTER
CONSIDERATION OF OUR EMPLOYEE
PERSPECTIVE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP CRAYON HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LANDS
OF TAXPAYER ADVOCATES WE ARE A
TRADE ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTING TAX AGENTS WHO
REPRESENT TAXPAYERS FOR THE
COUNTY ASSESSOR ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD AND FROM TIME TO
TIME BEFORE THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
I WANT -- TO KEY OFF OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND WITH
RESPECT TO THIS COMMITTEE --
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS US IS
SAYING -- THE LONG ROAD TO
REFORM IS CERTAINLY ONE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE AND ANY COMMITTEE
OR THAT HAS JURISDICTION OVER.
ANOTHER AGENCY SHOULD TAKE A
LOOK AT WE THINK THAT THIS
MEASURE.
DEALS WITH ONE AGENCY AND ONE
AGENCY ALONE AND DOES NOT
EXAMINE THE TOTALITY OF THE TAX
ADMINISTRATION AND TAX WOULD YOU
TO CATION.
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA AND IT
HAVING SPOKEN WITH MANY OF YOU
THERE'S AN INTEREST IN GREATER
EFFICIENCY I DON'T THINK ANYONE
WOULD OPPOSE THAT.
WOULD RATHER THAN JUST LOOKING
AT ONE YOU OUGHT TO LOOK AT ALL
OF THE TAX AGENCIES THERE ARE
CURRENTLY.
FIVE NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO THE
ISSUE OF OVERSIGHT AND I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT ELECTED BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION WILL PROVIDE
MORE ROBUST OVERSIGHT OVER THE
ASSESSMENT AND ASSESSMENT
APPEALS PROCESS.
BOTH IN TERMS OF THEIR AND THEIR
AUDITS -- THE PERIODIC AUDITS OF
COUNTY ASSESSOR'S -- AS WELL AS
THEIR REVIEW OF THE RULES THAT
GOVERN PROPERTY TAX
ADMINISTRATION AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL I CAN TELL YOU THAT I HAVE
BENEFITTED GREATLY FROM THIS IS
A PRAY AS OVERSIGHT AND I KNOW
THAT WE ALL.
HAVE OCCASIONALLY -- ARE
IMPROVED BY PEOPLE TAKING AN
AUDIT OR LOOKING AT US FROM A AN
OVERSIGHT PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK THE IMPORTANCE OF A ROLL
OF AN ELECTED BE -- WE IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE AND I'LL POINT
TO AN EXAMPLE THAT WE HAD.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WITH THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION.
THERE WERE ISSUES THAT WE HAD
WITH ASSESSORS IN ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD.
THAT WERE NOT ADDRESSED IN
INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS WITH
ASSESSORS -- THAT WERE FINALLY
ADDRESSED -- BY B. O. E. MORE --
MEMBERS AND IN FACT IT WAS THE
CURRENT STATE TREASURER FIONA MA.
WHO REALLY -- TOOK THE ISSUE --
BY THE HORNS AND ENSURE THAT BY
THE END OF LAST YEAR THAT THE
BOP ADOPTED REFORMS TO THE
ASSESSMENT PROCESS BY WHICH
PROPERTY OWNERS CAN BRING THEIR
THEIR APPEALS. TO THE ASSESSMENT
APPEALS BOARD OR SEEK RELIEF
FROM THE ASSESSOR.
AND FINALLY -- AB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX AND WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND I APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE
THOSE BUT LACKS DETAIL IT SIMPLY
TAKES THE EXISTING B. O. E..
SPORTS IT APART AND AND SHOVES
IT INTO THESE TWO AGENCIES THE
ISSUE THAT THE AUTHOR HIMSELF AS
ADDRESSED.
IS THE ONE OF A A LACK OF
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF BEING OF
HAVING TAXPAYERS HAVE A TRUE --
REPRESENTATIVE ON MATTERS THAT
ARE BEFORE THEM EITHER IN TERMS
OF STATUS AS PROPERTY OR MATTERS
THAT ARE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AND I THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE LOOK AT FINDING NOT A
STAFF MEMBER WHO WILL LOOK TO
THE ASSESSOR'S OFFICE AND ASK
THOSE IMPORTANT CRITICAL
QUESTIONS.
BUT THAT'D BE A PEER WHO IS AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL AS WELL -- WITH
FOR THAT WE ASK FOR YOUR COULD
YOUR CONSIDERATION IN YOUR
NOTEBOOK.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SAID
NGUYEN LOMBARD ON THE PRESIDENT
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
CHAIRMAN BURKE VICE CHAIR BRAWL
HONORABLE MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WANTS
TO EXPRESS.
OUR FIRM OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
SEVENTY SIX WHICH WOULD END THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AND
ELECTED REPRESENTATION.
CORD DEDICATED SPECIFICALLY TO
TAX ISSUES.
WE ARE VERY PERPLEXED THAT THERE
ARE SUCH DEDICATION AMONG SOME
OF OUR FRIENDS TO END THE BOARD
OF IT OF EQUALIZATION WHICH
REPRESENTS. TO THE TIME WHEN THE
FIRST TWO ELECTED AFRICAN
AMERICANS HAVE SERVED ON THE
BOARD WOULD BOTH SERVING AS
CHAIR WE ARE NOT ATTEMPTING TO
DRAW ANY CONCLUSIONS HERE.
BUT WE WOULD LIKE.
WE WOULD.
BE SORELY REMISS TO NOT RAISE
THE QUESTION.
BEFORE YOU VOTE TODAY.
AS YOU KNOW ACCORDING TO OUR
MISSION STATEMENT THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
MISSION IS TO PROVIDE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES WOULD STRENGTHEN
OUR MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS IN
THEIR REGIONS AND OPERATIONS.
AND TO ADVOCATE ADVOCATE
POLICIES WHICH IMPROVE BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS ABOUT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA.
PART OF OUR PROVIDING SERVICE TO
OUR MEMBERS IS HAVING REPPERT IF.
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO CAN TURN
TO WHO UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS AND
INTERESTS OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING
STRONG BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES IN
AFRICAN AMERICAN EIGHBORHOODS.
WHEN IT COMES TO TAXES WE WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT BLACK
BUSINESSES PAY TAXES?
IN ADDITION TO INCOME TAXES
SALES TAXES AND USE TAXES
PAYROLL TAXES WE ALSO PAY
PROPERTY TAXES.
IT IS NOT JUST CONVENIENT FOR
OUR BUSINESSES TO HAVE ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO TURN TO WHEN WE
HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT TAXES.
OUR UP TO OUR COMMUNITIES NON
PROFITS ALSO NEED ASSISTANCE AND
NAVIGATING THE COMPLEX WORLD OF
CALIFORNIA'S TAXATION.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT OUR MEMBERS
TO BE DIRECT HAVE A DIRECT LINK
TO THE ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO CAN
LISTEN WITH INTEREST AND BE OUR
ADVOCATES WHEN NECESSARY.
IT IS WRONG TO TAKE AWAY OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS DIRECTLY
TO FACE TO FACE ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO ARE PREPARED TO
REPRESENT AFRICAN AMERICAN
BUSINESSES.
WELL WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
FAIR AND EQUITABLE TAX TREATMENT.
IF YOU VOTE YES ON AB FIVE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR CLOSING THE
DOOR IN OUR FACE.
OF THESE AFRICAN AMERICAN
BUSINESSES IF YOU TELL US THAT
WE SHOULD SETTLE FOR CALLING
BUREAUCRATS.
AND HOPING THAT THEY WILL RETURN
OUR CALLS.
THIS BILL IS TELLING US
SOMETHING STRANGE ESPECIALLY NOW
WHEN OUR COMMUNITIES NEED
REPRESENTATION ON SO MANY ISSUES.
THE REPRESENTATION FOR US IS NO
LONGER IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY NOW THAT WE HAVE.
OF REPRESENTATION ON THE BOP.
IF OUR FOUNDER OVER STONE.
WOULD HAVE BEEN HERE.
AND NEW WELL.
WHAT WAS GOING ON TODAY HE WOULD
SHAKE HIS HEAD IN AMUSEMENT?
HE WILL BE SADDENED BY AFRICAN
AMERICAN BUSINESSES WERE BEING
ASKED TO TAKE A STEP BACK AND
SETTLE FOR LESS THAN FULL AND
COMPLETE REPRESENTATION.
WE ARE HERE ASKING FOR THE
ELECTED OF A REPRESENTATION FULL
AND COMPLETE REPRESENTATION
CONTINUE FOR AFRICAN AMERICAN
BUSINESSES.
WE ASK FOR YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NO
ON AB.
FIVE SEVENTY SIX ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
JUST THE ONE THE GENTLEMAN THAT
SPOKE TO TALK ABOUT THERE'S FIVE
DIFFERENT TAXING AGENCIES -- IT
IS THE GOAL WITH CD TFA TO
BECOME THE ONE STOP SHOP FOR ALL --
FIVE AGENCIES IS IS THAT THE
GOAL.
THE END THAT'S THE CONVERSATION
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE HAVING AS
WELL HI I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THAT'S I'D LIKE TO SEE US GET TO
SOME PLACE.
OF WHERE WE HAVE A TAX AGENCY
THAT COULD BE A SERVE AS A ONE
STOP SHOP -- I THINK
THE ACA.
MORE SO THAN THIS BILL.
IS WHERE WE REALLY HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
THIS MERELY JUST SAYS IF THE ACA
WERE TOUGH PASS.
BOTH HOUSES IF IT WAS TO PASS A
PUBLIC VOTE.
HOW WOULD WE DETERMINE WHAT THE
REST OF THE DUTIES CURRENTLY?
THAT THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
HAS IS -- DISSEMINATED AND
ADDRESSED.
SO.
I WOULD LIKE FOR US TO ACTUALLY
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
THINK -- THERE IS ALSO
FRUSTRATION.
ABOUT -- THE NUMBER OF PLACES
THAT EVERYONE NEEDS TO GO TO LET
ALONE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE ALSO
DEALING WITH NOT JUST FEDERAL
STATE.
AND LOCAL ADMINISTRATIONS FOR
TAX PURPOSES.
IN LOS ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE
THERE'S THE BUSINESS TAX THAT.
REALLY CREATES -- A LOT OF
CHALLENGES FOR SPECIALLY SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT OPERATE OUT OF
THEIR HOME.
AND A LOT OF TIMES THEY END UP
MISSING THE DEADLINES AND THEN
HAVE TO FIND OUT AFTER SUS
SEVERE PENALTIES HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED SO.
I AM VERY SENSITIVE TO THAT AS A
FORMER SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
MYSELF I I RECEIVE THOSE NOTICES.
SO I I AM HAPPY TO DISCUSS
MOVING FORWARD HOW THAT GETS
ADDRESSED.
SO THEN THE SECOND.
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH.
AND IN FOR FOR SOMEBODY LIKE ME
THAT WANTS TO WANTS GOVERNMENT
TO BE EFFICIENT -- I DON'T
PHILOSOPHICALLY HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH REORGANIZATION FACT I THINK
IT WOULD MAKE SENSE. FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO TO DO THAT I'M
SOMEBODY WOULD WOULD ADVOCATE
FOR A ONE STOP SHOP.
I HAVE ONE AGENCY THAT COLLECTS
ONE STATE AGENCY COLLECTS ALL
THE STATE.
A STATE REVENUE -- BUT IN THE
SECOND QUESTION IS WILL WHO IS
THE ULTIMATE ARBITER OF OF THAT --
SHOULD IT BE A BUREAUCRAT --
THAT MAKES THOSE DECISIONS --
SHOULD BE SOME OF ITS APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR SHOULD THERE BE
A BOARDS APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
OR SHOULD THOSE BE ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT MAKE -- THAT THE
THAT MAKE THOSE APPOINTMENTS --
TO MAKE THOSE THOSE DECISIONS
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
ARGUMENTS THAT I HEAR FROM --
THE FOLKS THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION IS THAT THEY WERE
BUT THAT THEY WERE VOTED BY DULY
ELECTED.
BY THE PEOPLE OF OF CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE THESE DECISIONS AND WE
SHOULDN'T LET THOSE DECISIONS BE
MADE -- PUT PUT IN THE HANDS OF
OF OF OF ANOTHER BOARD I REALIZE
THAT'S NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
THIS -- AND THE AND THE AND THE
BUT THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE US
BUT IT DOES STILL APPLIED IS
STILL GERMANE. TO THE
CONVERSATION SO -- YOU KNOW GET
WHAT WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON ON
THAT IT'S GERMANE AND AND I I
WAS SMILING AS YOU WERE SAYING
THIS BECAUSE YOU KNOW UP WHILE
WHILE WE WOULD ALL DISCUSS THE
MERITS OF THAT ISSUE IT ALSO
TAKES A CERTAIN INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
BEEN A STAFFER. FOR A LONG TIME
AND SEEN WHAT REPRIEVE TO
CONSTITUENTS MEANS -- JUST TO
USE THE PREVIOUS BILL THAT WE
JUST LET YOU ALL VOTED ON WHICH
EIGHT THANK YOU -- FOR A. B..
THREE FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS A
ISSUE THAT CAME TO ME BECAUSE OF
A CONSTITUENT.
WHO HAD PENALTIES?
AT LEVELS WHERE.
THERE WAS NO WAY HE WAS GONNA
MAKE THOSE PAYMENTS.
AND IF IT WAS RUNNING FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS.
AND SO WHEN WE WORKED WITH.
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES.
WE THEN STARTED TALKING TO
DIFFERENT ATTORNEYS.
OF GOING BACK TO WHAT WE WOULD
DO A STAFFERS AND AND WE REALIZE
THAT.
COURSE MY STAFF WAS DOING THIS
AND WE REALIZE THAT THERE WAS A
BILL IN NEED TO ADDRESS.
AND CHANGE THE PRACTICES IN
PLACE WHEN WE TALK TO FTP THEY
SAID THAT THEY HAD WANTED TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THEMSELVES.
BUT THAT THEY JUST HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE.
TO AND SO WE OFFER TO DO A BILL
AND WORK WITH THEM. TO ADDRESS
IT -- REASON WHY I BRING THIS UP
IS BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY.
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS. TO LISTEN
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS AND ADDRESS
THE NEEDS IF.
THAT SAME INDIVIDUAL WHO CAME TO
ME.
HAD COME TO YOU AND YOUR
DISTRICT YOU WOULD HAVE DONE THE
SAME -- IN FACT I I WOULDN'T OF
TURN THEM OVER TO ANY OTHER
AGENCY I WOULD CALL THE AGENCY
MYSELF AND SAY.
I WANT TO KNOW EDUCATE ME ABOUT
WHY THIS ISN'T WORKING OR WHY
THIS ISSUE IS FALLING APART.
AND WHY IS IT THAT.
THIS HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED FOR
THIS LONG OF A TIME.
WE'VE ALL AT AND ANOTHER PART OF
THIS IS THAT WE EVOLVE.
AND WHAT WE SAW THAT THERE WAS A
NEED FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
YEARS AGO WE WE SEE THAT WE
MIGHT NOT NEED AT THIS POINT.
BECAUSE ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT
MOST OF THE CORE FUNCTIONS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN AWAY.
THAT OF WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BETTER MAKE SURE THAT FTP
OR OTHER AGENCIES HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED HOW WE MIGHT
NEED TO CHANGE.
THE WAY THEY CURRENTLY DO THINGS
SO THAT THESE ISSUES ARE BETTER
ADDRESSED.
RATHER THAN TRY TO HAVE SO MANY
DIFFERENT OFFICES.
EACH ONE POINTING FINGERS.
I THINK I THINK THAT'S BEEN ALL
OF OUR STRUGGLE I KNOW AS CHAIR
OF AGING AND LONG TERM CARE
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IN
THAT SPACE.
IS THAT AREA SEEMS TO HALL HAVE
BEEN DECIDED UPON BASED ON
DEFAULT RATHER THAN THERE BEING
A PLAN.
AND AND I FEEL LIKE THIS IS BEEN
SOMEWHAT.
QUICKLY AT A QUICKLY BUT THIS IS
BEEN AN AREA WHERE INSTEAD OF
HAVING ONE PLACE.
UP WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE AND AND
IT'S DISSEMINATED OUR ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY BE EFFECTIVE SO.
VERY LONG ABOUT ANSWER BUT BUT I
HOPE BY ADDRESSED SEVERAL ISSUES
IN. ONE ONE RESPONSE.
AND IF I DID AND I'M HAPPY TO
AND THEN MY MANAGER IF IT'S OKAY
ONE FOR ONE FINAL QUESTION IN IN
REGARDS TO TIMING ON THIS IF THE
ACA'S MOVING MOVING FORWARD.
AND THAT'S GOING TO GO BEFORE
THE VOTERS IS IT NECESSARY TO
HAVE -- THIS LANGUAGE -- MOVE IN
IN THIS -- THIS YEAR OR WOULD
TELL ME TO TALK ABOUT THAT OR
CAN WE WAIT UNTIL AFTER THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT IS IS
ADOPTED BY THE VOTERS TO BE ABLE.
TO IMPLEMENT SOMETHING SO THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION THE AC
DOESN'T HAVE A TIME LINE
NECESSARILY.
THAT THEN AND THAT'S WHY ONCE IT
GETS REFERRED TO A COMMITTEE AND
AND IT WASN'T REFERRED AND YET
BECAUSE OF THE COMPETING BILLS
HAVING TO DO WITH FISCAL RELATED
ISSUES.
SO ONCE THAT'S VOTED OUT AT THAT
POINT WE CAN DISCUSS THE MERITS
OF THAT ISSUE FOR AS LONG AS WE
WANT WE CAN PUSH IT.
INTO NEXT YEAR AS WELL.
BUT BECAUSE OF THIS BILL HAVING --
TIMELINES INSERT SPECIFIC
DEADLINES ASSOCIATED WITH POLICY
AND FISCAL AND THEN FLOOR VOTE.
WE AYE THIS AYE AYE WE PRESENTED
IT THIS YEAR SO THAT IT MOVES
FORWARD -- AND AT SOME POINT WE
CAN ADDRESS THE THE MAIN ISSUES
AND OBJECTIVES THROUGH THE ACA --
THAT'S ONE OF AND I HOPE BY.
RESPOND AT THE HEART OF THE
ISSUE OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT I DON'T WANT TO GO ON TOO
LONG.
SO IN A ROOM.
ONE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO.
ASSEMBLY MAN I MISSED THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THE PRESENTATION
DID YOU AGREE TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENT.
SO -- IF THE AC OR TO PASS IT
DOESN'T AFFECT THE CURRENT
COMPOSITION OF THE BOARD THAT
THE EFFECTIVE DATE WOULD BE.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IF THE ACA
WERE TO PASS OR WOULD IT TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY UPON PASSAGE --
I DON'T WE CAN'T BUY PASSED THE
ACA SO THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
TAKEN UP IN THE ACA WHICH RIGHT
A LOT WILL BE JUST.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS FOR THE ACA
WE'VE ALREADY DISCUSSED YES THE
AUTHOR THAT THAT THAT.
THAT THOSE KIND OF CONVERSATIONS
THERE THERE WILL BE A MUCH MORE
IN DEPTH CONVERSATION WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE ACTUAL ACA
WHICH THAT NEEDS TO BE A PORTION
OF THE ACTUAL HCA OKAY NOT THIS
PARTICULAR PORTION NOT THIS
COMPANION NOW OKAY.
THIS -- JUST HONESTLY.
AS HARD AS IT IS TO SEPARATE
THIS IS JUST A BASIC STRUCTURE
IF THE ACA IS TO MOVE ALL THE
WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SO I TOLD THE SETTLEMENT --
EARLIER TODAY I AM UNDECIDED ON
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION OF
WHETHER NOT TO ELIMINATE THE
BOARD I'M STILL FEELING MY WAY
THROUGH THAT GIVEN THAT WE'VE.
WE'RE JUST COMING OFF OF A MAJOR
RESTRUCTURING OF THE B. O. E..
AND THE FUNCTIONS OF THE BE -- A
LOT DO WE EVEN KNOW WITH THE
EFFICACY OF THOSE CHANGES WHILE
WE'RE CONTEMPLATING ANOTHER
CHANGE -- SO I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS JUST RUN TIMELINE IN
PHASING.
I'M GONNA LEAVE THE THE SORT OF
ULTIMATE VOTE -- ON A SEE A AN
OPEN QUESTION UNTIL WE HAVE SOME
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
OF SO WANTED YOU. TO BE AWARE OF
THAT -- I THINK WHAT'S GIVE ME A
LITTLE BIT OF PAUSE IS ARE ARE
SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS I'VE BEEN
CONTACTED BY FOLKS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THIS THIS IS GETTING GETTING
QUITE A BIT OF ATTENTION.
NOW AND AGAIN I DID SUPPORT THAT
THAT RESTRUCTURING.
AND AND THINK THIS IS A VALID
CONVERSATION TO HAVE -- BUT DO
WE ELIMINATE AN ELECTED BOARD --
WHICH IS A CONDUIT FOR THE
TAXPAYERS AT A TIME WHEN I HOPE
WE ENGAGE IN A FULL FLEDGED
CONVERSATION AROUND TAX REFORM.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE
GOT A HIGHLY VOLATILE -- TAX
STRUCTURE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN CORPORATE
LOOPHOLE CHANGE ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY BALLOT WHICH I HOPE WILL
ENCOURAGE A LARGER CONVERSATION
AROUND THE WAY WE DO TAXES IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO -- I'M LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE
IN THE BROADER CONTEXT OF HOW
ALL OF THESE THINGS.
WORK TOGETHER.
OR COMING UP WITH A STRUCTURE
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE SO
THAT.
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION I'M I'M
STILL GRAPPLING WITH BUT AS FAR
AS WHAT REMAINS IN THE BILL
TODAY TO KEEP THIS CONVERSATION
GOING IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT
THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
STAKEHOLDER.
A CONVERSATIONS ALL SUPPORT THE
BILL.
TODAY BUT WOULD WELCOME
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU PRIMARILY ABOUT HOW THIS
CHANGE.
FITS INTO THE LARGER
CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE AROUND.
TAX REFORM AND HOW WE MODERNIZE
THE WAY WE DO ALL OF THIS.
AND I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THIS FITS INTO THAT.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU PUSHING
THIS CONVERSATION I THINK IT'S
ONE WE NEED TO HAVE.
I DO HOWEVER THINK WE ALSO NEED
TO LOOK AT THE TIMELINE ISSUES
THE BALLOT SCHEDULE.
IN ALLOWING SOME TIME FOR THE
REFORMS. TO THE EVALUATED BEFORE
WE CAN TAKE ADDITIONAL ACTION.
BUT ALL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
BUT WELCOME A BROADER
CONVERSATION WITH THE CHURCH
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR GRAMM.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR ALL REFLECT THE
COMMENTS OF BOTH MY COLLEAGUES --
OUR COMMAND THE AUTHOR IN.
WORKING TO CREATE A MORE
EFFICIENT.
STRUCTURE FOR THE TAXPAYER --
YEAH THAT'S CERTAINLY AN ONGOING
EFFORT THIS INSTITUTION TO BE
ANCIENT.
LIKE MISTER MALL AND I HAVE --
RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
ELIMINATION THE BOP AND IN FACT.
EVEN THE RESTRUCTURING THAT THIS
BODY UNDERTOOK -- PREVIOUSLY --
I'VE HAD SECOND THOUGHTS ABOUT --
THE WISDOM OF THAT.
GIVEN THE EXPERIENCE.
YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT HAS HAD IN
WORKING WITH.
IRAN ON ELECTED WATER BOARD --
AND THE STAFF.
AT THOSE INSTITUTIONS -- GIVEN
EXPERIENCE MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS IT HAD AT THE DMV
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
[inaudible]
THIS BODY.
HAS NOT DONE A GREAT JOB OF
OVERSIGHT OF AGENCIES AND WE'VE
SEATED A GREAT DEAL OF AUTHORITY.
A YEAR IN AND YEAR OUT
PARTICULARLY DURING THIS ERA OF
TERM LIMITS WITH THE LEGISLATORS
COMING AND GOING EVERY THREE OR
FOUR YEARS ON AVERAGE -- AND AT
THE END OF THE DAY I STRUGGLE
WITH THE IDEA OF THESE
BENEVOLENT DICTATORSHIPS.
RIGHT DEMOCRACY NOT BUREAUCRACY.
NEEDS TO BE OUR NEEDS TO BE OUR
TEAM AROUND HERE AND THEN TELL
THIS INSTITUTION -- RE ENGAGES
IN A SERIOUS MANNER AND
OVERSIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU STEPS APPROPRIATE RIGHT --
I UNDERSTAND THE BILL BEFORE US
TODAY.
SET IN PLACE TO STRUCTURE.
IF THE ACA WERE TO PASS.
HAVING SAID THAT THE OTHER THING.
THAT'S BECOME ALL TOO COMMON
PLACE -- HERE IN OUR INSTITUTION
IS THIS NOTION OF MOVING THINGS
ON DEADLINES [inaudible]
THERE'S NOTHING.
IT FRUSTRATES ME MORE THAN TO BE
AND YOU KNOW LAST POLICY
COMMITTEE OF THE SECOND HOUSE
AND HAVE SOMEONE SAY -- IT'S A
WORK IN PROGRESS.
AND TOO OFTEN WE HEAR THAT RIGHT
WHERE WE FIND OURSELVES IN THE
FIRST CALL SEE COMMITTEE OF THE
FIRST HOUSE IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
A TWO YEAR SESSION.
WITH AN ACA THAT WOULD BE SET TO
BE ON THE BALLOT.
IN A COUPLE YEARS RIGHT -- SO I
DON'T SEE THE NEED TO RUSH
FORWARD I THINK THIS IS A
CONVERSATION IMAGE ENGAGING WITH
YOU ON TO THE BENEFIT.
OF THE TAXPAYER BUT I'M NOT YET
CONVINCED THAT WE HAVEN'T GONE
TOO FAR IN THE DIRECTION OF
BUREAUCRACY AND MAY WE NEED TECH
TAKE A FEW STEPS BACK TOWARDS
ACCOUNTABILITY -- TOWARDS CHECKS
AND BALANCES -- AND NOT THIS
NOTION OF BENEVOLENT DICTATOR
STATE RUN AROUND -- AGENCIES
THAT THOSE OF US WHO WORK HERE
EVERYDAY CAN'T NAVIGATE.
YOU KNOW WE GO WORK IN OUR
DISTRICT OFFICE AND TRY TO HELP
CONSTITUENTS NOW TO GET SOME OF
THESE -- PROCESS AND THAT CAN BE --
INCREDIBLY FRUSTRATING
EXPERIENCE. FOR US -- AND
PROMOTION FOR THEIR CONSTITUENTS
SO UNFORTUNATELY I'M GONNA LAY
OFF THIS BILL TODAY -- BUT I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE -- ENGAGING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND AND HOPE THE
AUTHOR EMBRACES A DISCUSSION
ABOUT HER PRIVATE SOMETHING THAT --
BENEFITS TAXPAYER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATIONS AND
I KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME.
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS AS WELL
AND AND I THINK FOR THE MOST
PART WE AGREE -- AND HAVING HAD
THE BENEFIT OF BEING STAFFERS IN
THIS INSTITUTION AND SEEN HOW
DIFFICULT SOME CHANGES HAVE BEEN --
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING SO I'M I'M LOOKING
FORWARD -- TO GAINING YOUR TRUST
AND CONFIDENCE NOT TRUST BUT
YOUR CONFIDENCE ON THIS ISSUE --
AND AND I THINK -- AS IS I MAY
HAVE MENTIONED TO YOU I HAD
ASKED LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL TO
DRAFT.
THIS BILL LAST YEAR.
THE ONLY REASON I DECIDED NOT TO
INTRODUCE IT WAS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT TO SEEM LIKE THERE
WAS SOMETHING BEING BRUSHED.
I THOUGHT LET ME INTRODUCE AT
THE BEGINNING OF A START OF A
TERM.
SO THAT WE CAN.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THAT THE
ISSUE AND AND DISCUSS.
SO -- I TO APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND I I HOPE I CAN
CONVINCE YOU OTHERWISE THANK YOU.
QUIRK.
YEAH -- I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE VOTERS HAVE
AN IDEA WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
IF THE IF WE DO ABOLISH AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE UP TO THEM
ULTIMATELY IF WE DO ABOLISH.
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION AND I
THINK THIS BILL -- PROVIDES A
WAY TO DISCUSS THAT AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- YES I AGREE WITH
SOME OF MY FELLOW MEMBERS THAT
TAX REFORM IN A MUCH LARGER
CONTEXT AND MODERNIZATION OF OF
OUR TAX CODE IS IMPERATIVE AND
WE DO NEED TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND IT IS A VERY
CHALLENGING CONVERSATION AND
THAT WILL TAKE YEARS AND ITSELF.
HOWEVER -- AS THE REPRESENTATIVE
THE BE A WE EMPLOYEES HAD
MENTIONED THAT WHEN WE DID MAKE
THE LAST CHANGE THEY WERE FORCED
TO MOVE VERY QUICKLY.
AND THERE WAS NO STRUCTURE IN
PLACE WE DO NOT WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN AGAIN.
SO THIS THIS ITEM BEFORE US IS
NOT THE ACA IT'S NOT A DECISION
AS TO WHETHER WE WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE BE -- YOUR WHAT
HAPPENS.
TO THE WAY WE PROCESS THESE
THINGS MOVING FORWARD BUT IT IS
JUST MAKING SURE THAT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE A STRUCTURE
IN THE EVENT THAT THEY MAKE A
DECISION.
THE ACA TO TO VOTE ON A CA.
TO WITH THAT I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO MENTION TO THE CHAMBER THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN CHAMBER HERE.
THAT -- AS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
ELECTED OBVIOUSLY THIS BODY IS
VERY CONSCIOUS AND VERY AWARE OF
OF THE TH OF THAT OUR BODY AND
OUR COMMUNITY IS REPRESENTED
IMPOSSIBLE AND AND POSITIVELY
REFLECTED.
AS AN ELECTED AND I THINK WE'VE
DONE THAT QUITE WELL.
THE ACA WILL HAVE THIS IS NOT
THE ACA BUT ACA TO WILL HAVE A
STRENUOUS PROCESS IT WILL HAVE
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THE BE A WE DOES HAVE
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY DO
REPRESENT AND THEY ARE
PROCESSING.
THE THING A LOT OF OUR
CALIFORNIANS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF OUR MONEY SO
THIS WILL BE AN ONGOING PROCESS
I APPRECIATE YOU AS THE AUTHOR
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE PLAN ON
HAVING THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
ON THAT MEASURE.
ON THIS MEASURE HOWEVER YOU HAVE
A TO PASS ON TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I THINK YOU SAID IT BEST THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL TAKE THAT
AS THE AS THE CLOTHES AND WITH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I'M OF THE BILL.
YES I WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE BURKE
AYE BRO [inaudible]
RONELL [inaudible]
TO GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING MAYES.
HE'S OUT OF MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE PETRIE NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK ALRIGHT REAVIS REAVIS AYE
TING.
SOME COMPLETES ONE THAT'S ON
CALL IT NEEDS [inaudible]
ONE THANK YOU.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVEN AB.
SEVEN ONE SEVEN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO OPEN MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I'D LIKE TO FOR START BY EIGHT
THINKING YOUR STAFF -- FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN CREATES A
SAFER SYSTEM FOR COLLECTING
STATE TAX AND FEE PAYMENTS FROM
CASH BASED BUSINESSES INCLUDING
CANNABIS.
THIS BILL DIRECTS THE STATE TO
CONTRACT WITH AN ARMORED CAR
SERVICE PROVIDER TO SET UP AN
OPT IN PROGRAM FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESSES WISHING TO HAVE THEIR
CASH TAX.
AND FEE PAYMENTS PICKED UP
COUNTED AND TRANSPORTED TO A
BANK OVER FINANCIAL INSTITUTION.
I WILL THEN MOVE FORWARD AND SAY --
DID IN ABILITY TO WRITE CHECKS
MAKE AND TO MAKE AND RECEIVE
ELECTRONIC PAYMENTS OR ACCEPT.
CREDIT CARD AND DEBIT CARD MEANS
THE INDUSTRY DEALS WITH LARGE
SUMS OF CASH THAT'S WHY I AM
WORKING WITH VARIOUS ENTITIES TO
BRING THIS BILL FORWARD -- WITH
ME I'M JOINED BY HAYDEN TRAFFIC
ON BEHALF OF GUARD A WORLD -- TO
MAKE FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
WITNESSES THE POOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- I'LL KEEP MY
COMMENTS VERY BRIEF HERE -- I
REPRESENT GUARD A WORLD CASH
SERVICES ONE LARGEST ARMOR
TRANSPORTATION COMPANIES TO IN
THE COUNTRY WORKING WITH A
NUMBER OF AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE -- CITY'S MUNICIPALITIES
BECAUSE THERE IS A SERIOUS THE
SECURITY PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
HAVING TODAY WHERE TAXPAYERS ARE
QUITE LITERALLY PUTTING HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN CASH
AND IN A SUITCASE OR A OR THE
BACK OF THEIR CAR TO PAY THEIR
TAXES -- IN A GOVERNMENT
BUILDING AND WE WE NEED TO FIND
A SOLUTION IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
SAFELY AND SECURELY PAY THEIR
TAXES.
AND WHAT THAT'LL ALL COULD
CONCLUDE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANY FRANK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THIS IS A STRAIGHT FORWARD
MEASURE TO KEEP OUR EMPLOYEE
SAFE -- RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RIVAL THANK YOU.
REBECCA MARK AS REPRESENTING THE
HL COMPANIES AND SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NINE WOULD YOU LIKE
BECAUSE IRESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
BOOK.
THANK YOU HAVE ONLY BROUGHT
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BURKE AYE BRO.
WELL I CHU GRAY.
MAYES MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MULLIN ONLINE COUNTRY NORRIS
QUIRK HI.
I READ THIS.
REAVIS HIGH TAME ON COMMITTEES.
ONE THAT'S ON CALL IT NEEDS.
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THE THE FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
.
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR HE HAD A
TWELVE SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I SAW AN OPENING AND MY STAFF IS
NOW SCRAMBLING AND RUNNING DOWN
THE HALL.
TO COME DOWN BUT IF THAT'S OKAY --
TOO GO AHEAD AND PRESENT.
AB.
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR AB.
SEVENTY FOUR WILL EXEMPT ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT BUSES.
WAR Z. BEES FROM THE STATE
PORTION OF THE SALES TAX UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
IN ORDER TO ADVANCE THE
DEPLOYMENT.
OF CBS IN CALIFORNIA.
CEROMITIA BUSES RELY A BATTERY
ELECTRIC AND OR HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL TECHNOLOGIES AND ELIMINATE
EXPOSURE TO CONTAMINANTS.
UP EXCEPTIONALLY BENEFITING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
UTILIZE TRANSIT AT HIGHER RATES
CURRENTLY ALMOST HALF OF THE
STATE'S BUS POPULATION CONTAINS
DIESEL ENGINES WHICH AMID A
COMPLEX MIXTURE OF AIR
POLLUTANTS THAT CAUSE CANCER.
PREMATURE DEATH AND HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS TOP CONTRIBUTORS
TO CLIMATE CHANGE MANY TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA BEGUN TO
REDUCE THESE EMISSIONS BY
DEPLOYING Z. BEES.
AND DUE TO THE PASSAGE OF THE
CLEAN TRANSIT REGULATION IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IS NOW REQUIRING
THE STATE'S TWO HUNDRED PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO BEGIN
PURCHASING.
Z. BEES AS SOON AS TWENTY TWENTY
THREE WITH THE GOAL OF
CONVERTING ALL BUSES OPERATING
CALIFORNIA'S ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES BY.
TWENTY FORTY HOWEVER THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE CONSIDERABLY
MORE EXPENSIVE THE DIESEL
ALTERNATIVES AND TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE OFTEN CASH STRAPPED
LOSING MONEY AT THE FARE BOX.
AND RELYING ON FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL SUBSIDIES TO COVER CAPITAL
COST AB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
ASSIST TRANSIT AGENCIES AND
CONVERTING THEIR FLEETS TO ZERO
EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGIES BY
EXEMPTING XEVIOUS FROM THE STATE
PORTION.
OF THE SALES TAX FOR FOUR YEARS
HELPING AGENCIES OVER COMMON
IMPORTANT UP FRONT FUNDING
SHORTFALL IT CURRENTLY IMPEDES
THE PROCUREMENT OF ZEE BEES AND
RAMP UP. TO THE INNOVATIVE CLEAN
TRANSIT REGULATION AND I BELIEVE
I HAVE WITH ME THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
CAL START. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THREE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL UNTIL THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT CESSATION I WANT TO
START MY COMMENTS BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN AND OUR
PARTNERS AT PER TERRA FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD.
AS A KNOWLEDGE BY THE AUTHOR AND
BY THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE ARE MIGRATING TOWARDS YOUR
MISSION TECHNOLOGIES BY TWENTY
FORTY ALL TRAINS BUSES OPERATING
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ZERO MISSION.
NO UNFORTUNATELY THIS TRANSITION
IS GOING TO BE EXCEEDINGLY
EXPENSIVE WE DID OUR OWN
ESTIMATES OF WHAT THIS COSTS BUT
THE COST WILL BE AND WE ASK
MIDDLE BE UPWARDS OF THREE
BILLION DOLLARS.
SO TO COMPLY FULLY WITH THIS
INNOVATIVE CAN TRANSIT
REGULATION I TRANSIT AGENCIES
WILL REQUIRE CONTINUED AND
GROWING STATE SUPPORT -- WITHOUT
A CASH STRAPPED TRANSIT AGENCIES
WE FORCE TO MAKE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS -- WITH THEIR FINITE
BUDGETS POSSIBLY SACRIFICING
ROBUST RAN TO SERVICE TO
PURCHASE AND PLAY THESE MORE
EXPENSIVE BOSSES -- AT A TIME
WHEN BMT IS RISING AND SEE
STRUGGLING ENCOURAGE MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO CHOOSE TRANSIT
OVER THE CARS.
WE CAN ALLOW THE STREET OFFICE --
TO TO MANIFEST WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE TAX EXEMPTION
PROVIDES WOULD AUGMENT THE
SUPPORT THE STATE HAS ALREADY
PROVIDED THROUGH PROGRAMS LIKE
THE H. FIP.
ALLOWING TRANSIT AGENCIES TO
BRIDGET GRADY PORTION A GREATER
PORTION OF THE INTERNAL COSTS OF
THESE BUSES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BURKE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M RIGHT
INSURED WITH CAL START OR
TECHNOLOGY CONSORTIUM THIS AND
WORKING FOR THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS TO ACCELERATE THE
COMMERCIALIZATION.
OF CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGIES AND JUST TO SPUR
THE GROWTH OF THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
IN CALIFORNIA WE ALSO ARE THE
CONTRACT ADMINISTRATOR FOR H.
FAT.
OR THE HYBRID AND ZERO EMISSION
TRUCK AND BUS ABOUT YOUR PROJECT
WHICH IS WHICH IS LED BY CARB.
AND IT'S CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY
STATEWIDE PROGRAM FOR CLEAN
TRUCK AND BUS INCENTIVES AND
IT'S PUT ABOUT THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED TRACKING BUSES TRUCKS
AND BUSES ON THE ROAD SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN AS A RESULT OF
CALIFORNIA'S KIND OF POLICIES
POLICIES ZERO EMISSION BUS
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOW SETTING UP
SHOP IN THE STATE.
INCLUDE PATEROS MOTIVE YOU ID
CHANGE GREEN PARTY MOTORS
COMMONS AND MANY MORE -- MEDIUM
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES IT'S
GENERALLY ARE ONE OF THE STATE'S
MOST CONCENTRATED SOURCES OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
PRODUCING OVER -- WE'RE FIFTH OF
THE EMISSIONS WITH ONLY ABOUT 3%
OF THE VEHICLES.
THESE EMISSIONS AND POLLUTES
IMPACT LOW INCOME IN THIS AGE
VAN COMMUNITIES FIRST AND WORST --
AND LAST DECEMBER THEIR
RESOURCES WERE ADOPTED THE
INNOVATIVE CLEAN TRANSIT RULE
THAT REQUIRED TRANSIT AGENCIES
TEND TO CONVERT THEIR BUSES TO
HUNTER PERCENT ZERO EMISSIONS
OVER TIME -- WITH WITH THAT IN
MIND WELL THIS REGULATION IS
MOVING US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
YOUR MISSION BUSES STILL COST A
PREMIUM COMPARED TO CONVENTIONAL
DIESEL POWER TO NATURAL GAS
BUSES.
AND AT THE SAME TIME TRANSIT
AGENCIES STILL NEED TO
COMPLETELY DEVELOP NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE THE TAKES MANY
YEARS TO INSTALL.
AND AND ALSO COME TO TERMS WITH
A WHOLE NEW WAY OF OPERATING
CHARGING AND MAINTAINING THEIR
VEHICLES THE STATE'S EXISTING
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS INVESTING IS
AB TODAY ARE CRITICAL BUT
THEY'RE NOT ENOUGH.
MORE FUNDING IS NEEDED AND IT IS
NEEDED FOR MULTIPLE YEARS OUT.
ON THE MANUFACTURING SIDE IT
TAKES FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS TO
BRING A NEW PRODUCT TO MARKET
AND MANUFACTURERS ARE UNLIKELY
TO DEVELOP THE THE NEWER.
AND AN EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WE NEED UNLESS THEY HAVE A
CLEAR PICTURE OF THE FUTURE
DEMAND -- FROM FROM THE STATE.
INVESTING IS ABS ALSO SUPPORTS
OUR MISSION TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER
TO OTHER TECHNOLOGIES BEYOND --
BY BUS -- WE MUST CONTINGENT AS
THEMSELVES OR TO CREATE A
NETWORK THE FACT THAT WILL DRIVE
MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE
TRANSPORTATION DO IS FULL PART
IN REDUCING EMISSIONS.
AB SEVENTY FOUR HELP TO DO THIS
AND RESOLVE THE IMPORTANT
CHALLENGE OF CREATING THE NEW
RESOURCE FOR JOBS AND MEANING
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES MORE BROADLY
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM JERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME'S CLAIRE BANDS I'D WITH
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIES ON BEHALF
OF PER TERRA.
I'M FOR TERRA IS HEADQUARTERED
HERE -- WE HAVE NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES IN CALIFORNIA
AND ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
SPECIFICALLY FOR THREE THINGS
ONE EXCEL OR IN THE DEPLOYMENT
OF THEIR MISSION PUBLIC TRANSIT
BUSES WHICH WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN ALSO CALIFORNIA IS ONE
OF THE FEW STATES IN THE NATION
THAT ACTUALLY CHARGES SALES TAX
TO ITS PUBLIC TRANSITION SEES.
AND THERE'S A REAL NEED -- TO
REDUCE THAT AND ACTUALLY CLOSE
THE FUNDING GAP FOR OUR PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES AS WELL AS
CONTINUING TO GROW MANUFACTURING
JOBS RAISE YOUR MISSION PUBLIC
TRANSIT BUSES IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS HEIDI
SAID GRAHAM DIRECTOR OF IN YOUR
JEFF I MEANT FOR THIS LOOK ON
THAT LEADERSHIP GROUP WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF THEIR
MISSION BUSES THAT ARE
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE.
TOXIC EMISSIONS EMITTED BY
DIESEL AND CNG BUSES AND WHICH
WILL GROW LOCAL MANUFACTURING
JOBS.
NATIONWIDE AND SPECIFICALLY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBOOK.
SURE MEMBERS ROSS BUT THE ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS CON REPRESENTING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON HERE IN
SUPPORT.
NOT YOUR MOM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
I LANDED ON WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE WAY THE
AMERICAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- THANK
FOR ENTERTAINING -- THIS TAX
CREDIT MANAGE CHAIR MEMBERS --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN THAT TIME IS RIGHT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR LACKEY.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
TEN EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN.
MOVE THE BELL [inaudible]
IF YOU.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL.
AND WOULD CLEARLY BE HAPPY TO
TAKE THE COMMAND THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT --
AB NINETY FOUR WHICH CREATES A
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION FUND. TO
PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NEARLY FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS TOOK THEIR OWN LIVES.
MANY OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AS
SOON AS MANY OF THESE PEOPLE
WERE YOUNG PEOPLE.
SUICIDE IS THE SECOND AND THIRD
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS.
THIS IS A STAGGERING INCREASE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE WERE
RATES WERE 50% LOWER.
MORE SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
CRISIS INTERVENTION SERVICES ARE
NEEDED FOR THE AT RISK
POPULATIONS.
PARTICULARLY THOSE A RURAL
LOCATIONS AND AMONG THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
SUICIDE IS MOST PREVALENT IN
RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE
THERE ARE FEWER CENTERS.
SUICIDE IS ATTEMPTED MORE
AMONGST LGBT YOU THINK A PERSON
TO THEIR HETEROSEXUAL PEERS.
AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR CREATES A
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION. TO
ADDRESS THE URGENT NEED OF THE
STATE AND GIVES A HIGHER
PRIORITY TO NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS LOCATED IN RURAL
AREAS.
THOSE HAND ALSO TO OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WITH STAFF TRAINED
TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO LGBT
INDIVIDUALS.
THIS BILL HAPPENS TO HAVE
BIPARTISAN AUTHORSHIP.
AND HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
TREVOR PROJECT A LEADING SUICIDE
PREVENTION ORGANIZATION FOR L.
G. B. T. YOUNG PEOPLE.
I HAVE WITH ME -- MANISHA PATEL
AND SAM BRITAIN.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME I'M A
CLINICAL SUPERVISOR MENTAL
HEALTH -- AGENCY NONPROFIT IN
THE I'M A VALLEY.
AND THERE IS A STRONG NEED IN
OUR COMMUNITY -- FOR MORE
SERVICES -- TO PREVENT SUICIDE
FOR OUR YOUTH AND SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE LGBT Q. OUR COMMUNITY --
THERE AT A HIGHER RISKS FOR
VARIOUS -- PROBLEMS SUCH AS
SUICIDE SUBSTANCE ABUSE HEALTH
RISKS.
AS WELL AS VIOLENT -- ARE SAFE
VIOLENT CRIMES ARE SAFETY --
ISSUES THAT THEIR FACE AN
ONGOING BASIS THEY ALSO LACK A
LOT OF SUPPORT AND ACCEPTANCE
FROM NOT ONLY THEIR FAMILY.
BUT POSSIBLY THERE ARE CLERGY
AND OTHERS IN THE COMMUNITY SO
THERE'S A BIG STICK IN MY THAT --
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND BY
PROVIDING MORE SERVICES AND
AWARENESS IN OUR COMMUNITY WE BE
ABLE TO SERVICE.
THE SPECIFIC POPULATION --
THROUGH VARIOUS EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES AS WELL AS BEING
TRAUMA INFORMED AND CULTURALLY
COMPETENT.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THEIR
SPECIFIC NEEDS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SAM
BRINTON -- CHAIR BURKE AN
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- I SERVE AS OUR HEAD
OF ADVOCACY IN GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE TREVOR PROJECT I
WOULD LIKE TO RAISE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINETY FOUR
WHICH WILL CREATE A VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FUNDS WERE
DONATIONS CAN BE GIVEN. TO HELP
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
NEED TO PREVENT SUICIDE.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE TREVOR
PROJECT IS THE WORLD'S LARGEST
WITH A PREVENTION AND CRISIS
INTERVENTION PROGRAM FOR LG TO
YOUNG PEOPLE.
WE WORK TO SAVE LIVES BY
PROVIDING SUPPORT THROUGH FREE
CONFIDENTIAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
AND CRISIS INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
AVAILABLE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THE
A LIFELINE CHAT AND TEXT
SERVICES.
BY MONITORING ANALYZING AND
EVALUATING OUR DATA OBTAINED
FROM THE SERVICES WE ARE ABLE TO
CONDUCT CUTTING EDGE RESEARCH
THAT BRINGS NEW KNOWLEDGE.
WITH CLINICAL APPLICATIONS
REGARDING ELDERS YOUTH SUICIDE.
OUR DATA TELLS US THAT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ALONE APPROX MEDLEY 15%
OF THE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CONTACTS THAT WE
RECEIVED TO OUR CRISIS SERVICES.
THE CALLER SELF IDENTIFIED
THERE'S THE ZIP CODE CAM COMING
FROM A RURAL COMMUNITY LIKE
THOSE WHICH WOULD BENEFIT FROM
AB.
NINETY FOUR WE KNOW THAT ACCESS
TO SUICIDE PREVENTION RESOURCES
DEPENDING ON WHERE AN IMAGE
INDIVIDUAL LIVES AND RURAL AND
DESERT REGIONS.
TEND HAVE FEWER RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AS YOU'VE HEARD TO
OFFER COUNSELING SERVICES AND
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS.
AS YOU RECOGNIZE THIS CAN
INCREASE FEELINGS OF ISOLATION
DEPRESSION HOPELESSNESS ALL OF
WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO INCREASED
RISK OF SUICIDE ATTEMPT.
THE TREVOR PROJECT SUPPORT AB
NINETY FOUR WHICH WILL EXPAND
ACCESS TO SUICIDE PREVENTION
RESOURCES IN THESE RURAL AND
DOESN'T COUNTIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO CHOOSE TO DONATE A PORTION
OF THEIR PERSONAL INCOME TAX TO
THOSE SERVICES.
THIS WILL HELP PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING OUR LGBTQ
YOUTH BY PROVIDING GREATER
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE.
I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
RUSSIAN INJURY REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SCENE -- NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY THANK YOU THIS IS -- IT I
IT WAS REALLY HAPPY TO SEE THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU. TO BOTH OF YOU THAT ARE
HERE AND SUPPORT.
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YEAH ONE BECOMES -- AVAILABLE I
WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE WE CAN GET
YOUR SUPPORT AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THE TERM REGULAR.
WE COME BACK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
MOTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND OR VOTING.
HELLO WE NEED A SECOND.
NOW I HAVE A SECOND UNKNOWNS
EVEN SO WE HAVE A OKAY.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND WE HAVE A SECOND.
IN ORDER TO VOTE ON YOUR BILL.
I HOPE THAT'S BETTER YES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE HI BURKE I
PEARL. TO GRAY.
MAYES MULLIN THIS ONE TO FIVE
MULLIN.
BUT THREE NORRIS.
VETERAN OURS I QUIRK RIGHT.
I READ THIS.
WITH THIS I TING.
PHONE CALL THE ONE THAT'S ON
CALL ANYTIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
LIVING A FILE ITEM ONE AB
EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE WENT
TO LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF RECOMMENDING
SEVERAL TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN
THIS BILL WHICH I DO ACCEPT AB
EIGHTEEN WOULD IMPOSE A
STATEWIDE EXCISE TAX OF TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS.
ON THE SALE OF EACH HAND GUN AND
SEMI AUTOMATIC RIFLE THE REVENUE
WOULD ADD FUNDS TO THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE IN
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
GRANT PROGRAM CAL THAT.
TAX FUND THE EXCISE TAX ON FARM
RETAILERS PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
IS ANALOGOUS TO THE FEDERAL AID
IN WILDLIFE RESTORATION ACT.
COMMONLY CALLED THE PITMAN
ROGOSIN ROB ROBERTS AN ACT WHICH
IMPOSES A 10211% FEDERAL TAX ON
THE SALE OF GUNS AND AMMUNITION
BY MANUFACTURERS PRODUCERS AND
IMPORTERS.
REVENUES FROM THE PITTMAN
ROBERTSON TAX WHICH HAS BEEN
DESCRIBED AS A LEGISLATIVE MODEL
BY THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION FUND WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION EFFORTS THAT
REMEDIATE THE FACTS.
FARMS HAVE ON WILDLIFE
POPULATIONS THROUGH GAME HUNTING.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BOLSTER
VIOLENCE PREVENTION INITIATIVES
SO THAT THEY ARE COMMENSURATE
WITH OUR STATE'S TOUGH GUN LAWS
IN AS EFFECTIVE AS BOUNCE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS OF OTHER
STATES.
STRONGER SUSTAIN INVESTMENTS IN
CALVET WHICH THIS BILL WOULD
HELP PROVIDE WOULD ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO REPLICATE THE
EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS OF
MASSACHUSETTS AND SEVERAL OTHER
STATES TARGETED VIOLENCE.
PREVENTION INTERVENTION ISSUES
AND TO BETTER MEET THE ENORMOUS.
UNMET NEED IN OUR STATE FOR
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS SERIOUS
VIOLENCE IN THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- IS SANTA CORBIN WITH THE
GIFFORDS CENTER.
I'M NOT SUPPORTING THINGS FROM
THIS COMMITTEE LOOK AT
EVERYTHING YOU DO IT.
WELCOME WELCOME ON THE SUPPORT.
FIVE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU MY
NAME'S MATT THE CORPSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE DIFFERENCE LAW
CENTER. TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
URGING YOU TO SUPPORT SB
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE NOW LED BY FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN AND GUN VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR GABBY GIFFORDS THE
ORGANIZATION IS WORK FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO AN ACT
POLICY REFORMS AT THE LOCAL
STATE AND NATIONAL LEVELS TO
SAVE LIVES FROM GUN VIOLENCE.
THE ORGANIZATIONS TOP PRIORITY
THIS YEAR IN CALIFORNIA IS TO
INCREASE THE STATE'S INVESTMENTS
IN PROGRAMS THAT WORK TO
INTERRUPT CYCLES OF COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE INJURY TRAUMA AND
RETALIATION.
OTHER STATES ESPECIALLY NEW YORK
AND MASSACHUSETTS HAVE ACHIEVED
REMARKABLE REDUCTIONS AND GUN
VIOLENCE BY BOTH STRENGTHENING
THEIR GUN SAFETY LAWS AND
COMMITTING SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
FUNDING. TO EFFECTIVELY
TARGETING VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
GRANT PROGRAMS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAM
GRANT PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY
THE BOARD STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS PROVIDES COMPETITIVE
GRANTS TO CITIES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT IMPLEMENT
EVIDENCE BASED VIOLENCE
REDUCTION INITIATIVES -- CALVET
THIS CALPERS ONLY DEDICATED SORT
OF SOURCE OF STATE FUNDING
EXCUSE ME FOR THESE INITIATIVES
AND HAS PROVIDED CRITICAL
SUPPORT TO ADDRESS ON MY LANDS
IN JURISDICTIONS AROUND THE
STATE MOST IN NEED -- HOWEVER
AND UNFORTUNATELY STATE FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE OVER THE
YEARS AB EIGHTEEN LEVINE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CALVET PROGRAM BY
STATUTE AND PLACE A REASONABLE
SURTAX ON THE FIREARM INDUSTRY
IN ORDER TO FUND THOSE PROGRAMS
THROUGH COMPETITIVE.
NEED BASED GRANTS -- THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE AND HAVE BEEN PROVEN
TO BE AT REMEDIATING SOME OF THE
MOST DEVASTATING AFFECTS FIRE ON
PRODUCTS BECAUSE I'M FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EDITION OF WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AT OKAY
GOING ON BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN
FOR GUN SAFETY IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THE FIRST.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD.
THE IN RE WITH NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION HERE IN OPPOSITION.
I'M MORE OPPOSITION IS LIMITED
TO THE EXCISE TAX NOT ON THE
UNDERLYING GRANT PROGRAM.
I WOULD FEEL IF THIS IS A MATTER
PUBLIC SAFETY A. B. SHOULD BE
BURIED BY THE PUBLIC IN GENERAL
NOT SINGLING OUT.
LAWFUL GUN OWNERS WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATE MEANS TO
PURCHASE FIREARMS.
I'M YOU DID HEAR ABOUT THE
FEDERAL EXCISE TAX SUCH AS ONE
OF THE TAXES AND FEES A GUN
OWNERS -- FACE WHEN THEY ARE
GOING TO PURCHASE A FIREARM
THROUGH A DEALER.
SEE AT THE 11% FEDERAL EXCISE
TAX THE PITTMAN ROBERTSON WHICH
GOES TO HABITAT CONSERVATION
SHOOTING RANGES THINGS THAT
ACTUALLY BENEFIT GUN OWNERS --
AND WILDLIFE SUPPORTING OUR
NORTH AMERICAN MODEL OF
CONSERVATION.
ADDITIONALLY GUN OWNERS PAY
WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE TRUSTEE BUT
IT'S REALLY MADE UP OF SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PC OF THE NINETEEN
DOLLAR DROZ FEE.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY -- SUPPOSED TO
GO TOWARDS BACKGROUND CHECKS AS
WELL AS THE THE THE TRANSFER
REGISTRY -- THAT IS GOING TO
POTENTIALLY BE DOUBLED THIS YEAR
AND ANOTHER OF PIECE OF
LEGISLATION BEFORE THIS BODY --
WE HAVE THE ONE DOLLAR FIREARM
SAFETY ACT THE WE HAVE THE FIVE
DOLLAR SAFETY IN ENFORCEMENT FEE --
INITIALLY THERE'S A TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR FIREARM SAFETY
CERTIFICATE FEE.
THAT IS REQUIRED TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM AS WELL STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES GUN OWNERS ARE PAYING MORE
THAN THEIR FAIR SHARE -- BILLS
LIKE THIS AS WE CONTINUE TO ADD
ON OR JUST GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PRICE PEOPLE OUT OF THE MARKET
TO LEGALLY PURCHASE FIREARMS
WITHOUT MORE OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROY GRIFFIS
BEACON TODAY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISSED
ASSOCIATION -- CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL WILD TURKEY
FEDERATION ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK
AND MANY OTHER CONSERVATION
GROUPS.
I'M JUST A EXPAND UNETHICAL
ABOUT WHAT MY COLLEAGUE SAID.
THAT ROBINSON ACT LEVEL PERCENT
TAX BRINGING THE WORRY FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND A CALIFORNIA
ANALLY WHICH GOES TOWARDS GREAT
PROGRAMS AS OUTLINED INCLUDING
EDUCATION ON FARM SAFETY RUNNING
HER EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND OTHER THINGS.
SO THE LAW ABIDING GUN OWNERS
ALREADY PAID THEIR SHARE AND
THAT'S THE MAIN POINT WE WANT TO
SAY TODAY THIS TAX.
ON AS AGAIN ON A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT CAN ONLY THOSE MONIES CAN
ONLY GO BACK TO PAY.
FOR THE MINISTRATION OF THAT
PROGRAM NOT ON UNRELATED
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS COMMITTEE CAPULETS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
SAFARI CLUB INTERNATIONAL
OUTDOOR SPORTS MISS COALITION
CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY.
ALL IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND LIKE TO JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES -- AND
REALLY JUST ADD THAT -- WITH
SOME OF THE OTHER MAJORS LIKE
THE LEAD FREE -- AMMUNITION THAT
YOU'VE PASSES DRIVEN UP THE COST
THIS COMES AT A TIME WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO GET MORE.
HUNTERS IN YOUNG PEOPLE INTO THE
SHOOTING SPORTS THIS ARE ALL
DEBILITATING THINGS YOUR PRICING
FOLKS OUT OF THE MARKET
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL --
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION AND
THE RETAILERS ARE ALSO FACING
SEVERAL BILLS IN THE LEGISLATURE
THAT ARE GOING TO INCREASE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE STORES. TO
CARRY AMMUNITION AND FIREARMS
WHICH ARE GOING TO DRIVE UP THE
COST FOR THEM WHICH IS GOING TO
BE PASSED ALONG. TO THE CONSUMER
SO THIS IS BECOMING -- PUNITIVE
AND IN ESSENCE TAKING AWAY THE
RIGHTS OF NORMAL PEOPLE TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES AND HAVE
THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SAMPRAS REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA ONE ISSUE THAT WE HAD
HAVE NOT DISCUSSED.
AND THAT IS THE ACTUAL
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF CHARGING A
TAX ON THE EXERCISING OF A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT -- HAS
BEEN -- CONTROVERSIAL WILL
CONTINUE TO BE.
IN THE PEOPLE WILL SAY WHY
HASN'T -- ANYBODY CHALLENGE THE
PITTMAN ROBERTSON ACT -- EXCISE
TAXES JUST THEY HAVEN'T
CHALLENGED IT YET BUT NOW THERE
IS A CHALLENGE TO ATTACKS IN THE
FORM OF CAT LOVERS UNITED STATES
THE SUPREME COURT HAS OPENED UP
A DOCKET. TO ACCEPT DOCUMENTS
AND AND BRIEFS ON THIS CASE THIS
SPECIFICALLY CHALLENGES THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY.
OF ADDING AN EXCISE TAX ON THE
EXERCISING OF A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT -- THE COURT'S GOING TO
DECIDE THAT AND AND THIS ISSUE
MAM MAYBE DECIDED FOR YOU MAY BE
OUT A WAIT AND SEE WHAT THE
COURT SAYS.
BEFORE A PROGRESSING ON
SOMETHING LIKE THIS -- BECAUSE
IT JUST MIGHT BE OVERTURNED
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL ESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF THAT OUR
JOBS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE'RE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SOME OF MARYLAND AS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR -- MR LEVINE HOW DID
YOU ARRIVE AT THE AMOUNT OF
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
YEAH I THINK YOUR QUESTION --
THIS IS NOT THIS IS NOT A NEW
IDEA THIS IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING
THAT IS IN PLACE IN OTHER PLACES
IN OUR COUNTRY.
SO COOK COUNTY ILLINOIS CHICAGO
IS THERE HAS A TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR TAX SEATTLE AS WELL HAS
ONE SO THIS HAS SEEMED TO WORK
HAS NOT HAD UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT IS HOW WE LANDED ON
THAT FIGURE OKAY SO I GUESS.
YOU KNOW I'M THINKING ABOUT THIS
THE STATE'S THAT YOU --
REFERENCED WHICH ARE MUCH
SMALLER THAN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAD MUCH FEWER PEOPLE
SO I'M JUST NOT SURE THAT IT'S A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL WITH RESPECT
TO THE AMOUNT.
IN.
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE SO -- I GUESS
YOU KNOW SO MANY OTHER.
WAYS FOR MONEY TO GO INTO
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND ONE
PERSON THINGS LIKE THAT WHAT.
AMOUNT OF MONEY -- IS ENOUGH. TO
STOP GUN VIOLENCE.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN HAVE
A MUCH LARGER DIALOGUE ABOUT
THIS WOULD CREATE POTENTIAL
ABOUT TWELVE TO THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING EACH YEAR
WELL THAT FOR YOU KNOW A THIS I
AGAIN I THINK THAT'S UP FOR
DEBATE BUT THAT'S WHAT WE
PROJECT.
THAT THIS WILL COLLECT FOR THE
STATE.
I CAN ADD TO THAT ASSEMBLY
MOMENT OF NOW THANK YOU -- I
JUST I'M YOU KNOW I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
WE HAVE MONEY THAT GOES TOWARDS
YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE THIS ARE
READY RIGHT.
IN SO WE KEEP ADDING ON I GUESS
NO ONE SEEMS TO HAVE A CLEAR
VISION OF HOW MUCH IS ENOUGH.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S NEVER.
GOING TO BE ENOUGH AND I THINK
WE SHARE OBVIOUSLY -- THE DESIRE --
TO REDUCE VIOLENCE -- IT'S JUST
A MATTER OF OF HOW WE DO THAT
BUT THANK YOU -- ANSWERS I
APPRECIATE THAT -- TIME THE
TEMPORARY CHAIR -- BILL BRO IS
HERE.
WELL I'M NO LONGER THE TEMPORARY
CHAIR THE VICE CHAIR IS HERE.
ALL.
I CAN FINISH THE BELL IF YOU'D
LIKE ALL RIGHT DOES ANYONE ELSE
WISH TO SPEAK ON THE BILL --
SAID THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS IS APPROPRIATED.
AS SHE'S ME AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BOB PERSONALLY.
I DON'T THINK THIS TAX IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO SPOT TO FUNDED
HOWEVER I DO THINK WE NEED TO
FIND THAT AND FIND A BETTER
MECHANISM.
ON THAT BASIS I'M GOING TO VOTE
HI TODAY SO WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND SEE IF WE CAN
FIND A WAY TO FIND THIS -- THAT
HAS A BETTER NEXUS.
THAT BEING SAID WE NEED A MOTION --
ALL MOVED TO BAIL [inaudible]
MISS.
A REVISTA SECONDS THE BELL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BRO.
BRO NO CHU.
GRAY MAYES.
MAYES NOW MELINDA'S MELINDA SNOW
MALEN.
COUNTRY NORRIS QUIRK.
I WORK AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE.
KING.
MR SURE THAT'S BILL IS ON CALL
IT NEEDS.
FOR OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
NEXT IS THE ITEM.
EIGHT AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN MISS
PATTERSON [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY -- TO PRESENT
OUT AND WE'LL DO THIS -- QUICKLY
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
THE FACT THIS HAS SUPPORT
SUPPORT -- BACK IN -- TWENTY
FOURTEEN I WORKED ALONGSIDE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF MARK WITHIN
AND RICH GORDON TO RESURRECT THE
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM ALLOWS.
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE SENIORS AND
THOSE WHO ARE BLIND OR HAVE A
DISABILITY TO POSTPONE PAYMENT
FOR PROPERTY TAX ON THEIR
RESIDENCES.
THIS REALLY UP REMAINS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY FOR
HOMEOWNERS BECAUSE UNEXPECTED
INCREASES IN A TAX BILL.
CAN OFTEN TIMES -- FORCE THESE
HOMEOWNERS ON A FIXED INCOME TO
SELL THEIR HOMES EVEN THOUGH
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAS LAST YEAR
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
EVALUATED.
THE PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM AND PROVIDED A VARIETY
OF OPTIONS TO IMPROVE IT.
AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN WOULD
IMPLEMENT THE LA OWES
RECOMMENDATION TO REFINE THE
PROGRAM'S BASE INCOME LIMITS.
THE LOWER THE INTEREST RATE AND
ELIMINATE THE GENERAL FUND SWEEP.
THIS ENSURES THAT NOT ONLY IS
THE PROGRAM EQUITABLE AND
AFFORDABLE BUT THAT HOMEOWNERS
CAN SAFELY RELY ON ITS LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY.
THIS BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND I'M
PLEASED TO AGAIN JOINED TOGETHER
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC.
ELEMENTARY -- IMPROVE THIS
PROGRAM WE HE HAD TO BE --
ELSEWHERE FOR I THINK IT'S FIVE
MORE BUFFET -- COULDN'T BE HERE
BUT AT LEAST FOR THIS BILL I
THINK IT WAS HERE RECENTLY
WASN'T.
WE APPRECIATE HIS -- AUTHORSHIP
AS WELL WE HAVE DO HAVE WITH US --
MISS M. HOLLINGSHEAD WHO IS A
SENIOR FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WHO IS HERE TO PROVIDE.
A BRIEF OVERVIEW ON THEIR REPORT
AND BE AVAILABLE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE.
I AM CALLING SAID WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST
NOTED ON HERE IN AN
INFORMATIONAL CAPACITY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE --
PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
THE PROGRAM AS IT EXISTS TODAY --
AND OUR OFFICES REPORT THAT WE
RELEASED LAST YEAR I'M JUST WANT
TO REITERATE FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH OUR
OFFICES ROLE IN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE PROCESS IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WHERE WE DO TAKE.
POSITIONS ON GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS IN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE PROCESS WE DON'T EVER
TAKE A POSITION ON BILL SO
NEITHER FOR AGAINST -- SO THIS
PROPOSAL -- THIS PROGRAM THE
PROPERTY TAX PUT POSTPONED
PROGRAM AS IT CURRENTLY EXISTS
WAS FIRST ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN IT WAS
SUSPENDED IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
AND REESTABLISH IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN ESSENTIALLY OPERATES
LIKE A LOAN PROGRAM WHERE A
HOMEOWNER CAN APPLY TO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE AND HAVE
THEIR CURRENT YEAR PROPERTY
TAXES POSTPONED ON THEIR BEHALF
TO SEE WILL JUST PAY THOSE
PROPERTY TAXES ON THEIR BEHALF.
HOMEOWNERS CAN QUALIFY FOR THE
PROGRAM IF THERE OVER THE AGE OF
SIXTY TWO BLIND OR DISABLED IF
THEY HAVE HOUSEHOLD INCOME LESS
THAN THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AND IF THEY OWN AT LEAST 40%
EQUITY IN THEIR HOMES THE
HOMEOWNER OR THEIR HEIRS DO NEED
TO EVENTUALLY REPAY THE STATE
WITH INTEREST THAT INTEREST RATE
IS CURRENTLY SET AT 7% -- AND
THAT THAT ODDS THAT A HOMEOWNER
CAN DEFER THOSE REPAYMENTS
INDEFINITELY -- REPAYMENTS ARE
JUST TRIGGERED IF THE HOMEOWNER
CELLS THEIR HOME IF -- SOMEONE
INHERITS THE HOME OTHER THAN THE
SPOUSE AND AND THERE'S SOME
OTHER CONDITIONS AS WELL -- THE
PROGRAM IS ALSO IMPORTANTLY SELF
FUNDED SO DISBURSEMENTS ARE FOR
NEW APPLICANTS ARE COVERED AT
THE COST OF THOSE ARE COVERED --
BYE BYE COLLECTIONS FROM FROM
YOU -- FROM EXISTING
POSTPONEMENTS -- OUR P. R.
EVALUATION MADE A VARIETY OF
RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAD -- SO --
IDENTIFIED SOME ADVANTAGES AND
SOME SHORTCOMINGS OF THE PROGRAM
HAPPY TO WALK THROUGH THOSE IN
MORE DETAIL BUT IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME ALL STOP IT THERE.
THANK YOU TO SHOW WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MR TERM MEMBERS IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'LL BE BRIEF
TO DAVID WILL FOR THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY.
AND MEMBERS ALL JUST SAY OTHER
THAN PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE REGARDING CALLS
THAT WE GET TO OUR OFFICE IS ON
THE PROPERTY TAX PROS FROM A
PROGRAM.
IT'S INCREDIBLY VALUABLE
VALUABLE FIRST SENIOR MEMBERS.
AND IT KEEPS INDIVIDUALS IN
THEIR HOMES AND I THINK AS
SOMEONE AND AS PART OF AN
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTED THE
AMERICAN DREAM OVER THE YEARS
THAT'S HIGHLY HIGHLY VALUABLE --
SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS AND
ESPECIALLY WE ARE DEFINITELY IN
FAVOR OF THE LOWER INTEREST RATE
AND WANTING TO SEE THAT -- IN
ORDER TO ENCOURAGE GREATER
ENROLLMENT IN THE PROGRAM WOULD
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A THANK YOU
INITIAL SUPPORTERS.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISHING TO ASK
ANY QUESTIONS QUIRK.
YEAH -- ALL RIGHT MY PROBLEM IS
THAT IF YOU KEEP THE INTEREST
RATE THIS LOW IT'LL DESTROY THE
PROGRAM AT LEAST THAT'S THAT'S
MY READING FROM THE LA A REPORT.
WHICH SUGGESTS 5%.
ARM I COULD VOTE FOR THIS IF YOU
WOULD.
TAKE THE LA -- SUGGESTION AND
EITHER MAKE IT 5% OR MAKE IT A
FLOATING RATE.
BUT SETTING IT EXACTLY AT THE
PMR HIGH A RATE.
YOU'RE NOT EVEN MAKING UP FOR
INFLATION.
I COULD ACCEPT SOMETHING LIKE PM
MY A PLUS INFLATION OR SOMETHING
ELSE BUT MY CONCERN IS THAT THAT
THIS WILL DESTROY THE PROGRAM
IT'LL NO LONGER BE SELF FUNDING.
CAN YOU CONVINCE ME OTHERWISE.
WELL IT IF THE LA -- WANTS -- TO
ADDRESS THAT QUESTION -- I THINK
THAT'S MORE OF A TECHNICAL
QUESTION I I WOULD I WOULD
SUGGEST THIS -- THAT.
WOULD.
THE BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT SUPPORT
AND I HAVE NOT BEEN ASKED TO
CONSIDER OTHER AMENDMENTS AS
BEST I CAN TELL.
WELL I'M IN.
SO THAT PART OF THAT AS PART OF
THE AMENDMENTS THE AUTHORS
AGREED TO THE FOLLOWING THREE
OKAY CHANGES RATE 25% -- PERFECT
THEN.
FIVE NINE FIVE WHEN I WAS YEAH
OKAY AS LONG AS YOU'VE ACCEPTED
THAT AMENDMENT I'M FINE OKAY
WHAT WITH THE OTHER -- TO
ESPECIALLY -- STATE INCOME
LIMITS ARE JUST WILL BY
HOUSEHOLD SIZE THREE CORRECTED
NUMERICAL TYPE OF FINE PERFECT
OKAY I'M VOTING ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
I DO I MISUNDERSTOOD I LIKE IT
WELL I MISUNDERSTOOD I THOUGHT A
RESTAURANT.
NOW I KNOW IT COULD THANK YOU.
I AM GLAD I SECONDED THE BATTLE
OF OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WAS PERSONALLY LIKE
CLOTHES BOB SHOULD THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THANK YOU
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND I'VE LISTED THE AMENDMENTS
YOU'VE AGREED TO TAKE YES I HAVE
YEAH THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
PEARL.
BRO I CHU GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES HI MELINDA THIS MELENDEZ
AYE MULLIN PETRIE NORRIS.
BETWEEN NORTH AYE QUIRK NINE
WORK HI REAVIS REAVIS AYE TING.
THAT TELLS US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE EVERYONE.
WITH ONE FINAL ITEM FILE ITEM
ELEVEN A. B. TWELVE NINETY SIX
MRS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
IF FIVE SHE'S IN COMMITTEE OR
AVAILABLE COME DOWN A PERCENT.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR FINAL
AUTHOR WHY DON'T WE GO THROUGH
AND JUST NOT OFFICE.
WHAT WE CALL THE COLONY EIGHTEEN
LET'S START THERE THAT'S NUMBER?
ONE LET'S START WITH NUMBER.
ONE FILE ITEM ONE AB EIGHTEEN
THE CALL.
LET THE CALL CALL THE ABSENTEES
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GRAY
[inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PETRIE NORRIS.
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
ONE YEAH.
KING REPLACE THE CALL PLEASE
REPLACE THE CALL.
HERE'S MRS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
OUR FINAL ITEM IS FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN AB.
TWELVE NINETY SIX SORRY I'M NOT
A NO PROBLEM ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL.
THANK YOU I ADD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MARIO
DIBERNARDO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YOUR TO
SERRA WHO IS PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL -- THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT HAS WORKED WELL -- THE AG
HAS LED TO A MULTI AGENCY TASK
FORCE THAT GOES AFTER THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY FROM A TASK
TAX PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE.
TEAMS IN A A LOS ANGELES IN
SACRAMENTO THIS BILL WOULD
CODIFY THE PROGRAM AND EXPAND IT
TO THE OTHER THE OTHER MAJOR
METROPOLITAN REGIONS IN THE
STATE -- IT'S BEEN SUPPORTED BY
THE WHITE HOUSE -- GOVERNOR'S DO
SOMEBODY WAS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
AND THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
WHO WHO ORIGINALLY MADE THIS
RECOMMENDATION OF EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE AND I
DO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEHMET'S
THANK YOU.
I THINK IT IS SHOWING THIS ISN'T
SUPPORT.
HI KATIE DONAHUE DERON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
HERE IN SUPPORT THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL FOR RECOVERING REVENUES
FOR THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
SAY NON WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NON MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANYONE WISHING TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
THIS IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE RESPECT ASPIRIN
IVA.
THANK YOU THE RECOMMENDATION TO
PASS WITH THE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS H. CHAINS REPORTING
DATE FOR MARCH THIRTY FIRST OF
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER AND BE
REQUIRE THE LA -- ON OR BEFORE
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
EXAMINE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
TRUE PROGRAM ALONG WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
BRO.
BRO I CHU GRAY.
MAYES.
MAYES II MELINDA'S WINDESHEIM
MULLIN PETRIE NORRIS.
BUT TRAYNOR'S AYE QUIRK.
WORK I REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE TING.
WITHOUT THE BILLS OUT
[inaudible]
DAVID.
WE TOOK THIS ONE ANYTHING THAT
MOVES.
READ THOSE ARE THE CALLS.
THOSE FIRST.
WE'LL GO BACK -- TO MEMBERS
WISHING TO ADD ON FILE ITEM TO
WAS PULLED FILE ITEM THREE AB.
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
APRS LIVE THE CALL PLEASE CALL
THE OPTIMUM ALREADY PASSED LAWS
ARE CUSTOM.
CALL THE OLYMPUS.
MELENDEZ I MULLIN [inaudible]
GRAY REAVIS.
REVERSE AYE AYE KING. TO THE
POINT.
THOSE ARE THE ONES.
THAT ARE CROSSED OUT.
SELECT THIS ONE WOULD BE NEXT
FILE ITEM SIX AB.
FIVE SEVENTY SIX WITH THE CALL.
TO MELENDEZ [inaudible]
YEAH.
MELINDA SNOW.
COUNTRY NORRIS.
PUT YOUR NORRIS I THE BILL HAS
PASSED THE BILL IS PASSED.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB SEVEN
SEVENTEEN LIVE THE CALL
[inaudible]
CHU GRAY.
MAYES [inaudible] SEVEN MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
YES -- HI.
MAYES AYE MELENDEZ.
WHEN DOES NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
VETERAN YOURS I TING.
FILE ITEM.
TEN AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR LIVE THE
CALL [inaudible]
ROW.
HI.
BRO I TO GRAY MAY.
GRAY I MAYES MAYES I MULLIN.
MULLIN I TING.
THE BILL IS THAT BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWO ONE ONE
LET THE CALL [inaudible] SIXTEEN
TO EXCUSE ME -- GRAY
[inaudible] SIXTY GRAY AYE
MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S ARE MULLIN.
MULLIN I READ THIS.
REVERSE AYE TING THE THING I'D
THAT BILLS OUT THAT BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB FOUR
SIXTEEN LIVE THE CALL
[inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE REAVIS.
REVERSE AYE TING. SEVENTY FIVE
SEVENTY THE BILL IS OUT.
ALLEN NINETEEN A. B. FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE LIVE THE CALL
[inaudible]
GRAY.
GRAY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA SNOW MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE TING.
TING ON LIKE WE CAN GO BACK.
TO FILE ITEMNINETEEN PETRIE
NORRIS.
BUT YOUR NURSE FROM I TO NOT
VOTING.
THE BILL IS OUT -- WE NEED YEAH
WE WILL THIS ONE WE DO TO LIVE
CALL ON I NEED A LOVE TO CALL ON
FILING ONE A. B..
EIGHTEEN LET THE CALL
[inaudible]
BURKE CHIU [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
RAY I MULLIN.
MULLIN I TING.
TING ON SIX WITHOUT THAT'S OUT
SO NOW TO ADD ONS NOW WE'RE
GONNA PROCEED TO ADD ONS FIRST
ONE IS NUMBER.
THREE FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE
SEVENTY SIX CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
GRAY.
GRAY I'M MULLIN.
WELL IN HIGH TING.
TING I NUMBER.
FOUR FILE ITEM FOR A BI TO
NINETY SIX CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GRAY [inaudible] FOR
GRAY AYE MELINDA'S. ONE IS NOT
LOADING. ONE ONE DOES NOT VOTING
TO NOW [inaudible]
MULLIN.
I READ THIS.
RIVERS I CHING [inaudible] FIVE
FIVE I'M AYE.
ANIMALS SO WE'VE GOT NUMBER.
FIVE FILE ITEM FIVE AB THREE
FIFTY SEVEN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GRAY [inaudible] FIVE
GRAY NOT VOTING MELINDA'S
MELINDA NOW MULLIN [inaudible]
YES [inaudible] ONE I OKAY HOLD
ON JUST A MINUTE REVERSE.
REVERSE AYE TING. FOR FOR THE
SERVICE YES NO.
FIVE THREE FIFTY SEVEN ITEM FIVE
TING AYE.
MELINDA'S [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
NO TO AN ONLINE.
ON THREE FIFTY SEVEN CRACKED.
THE BILL IS.
THAT OKAY OKAY SOON NUMBER SIX
CLALLAM SIX AB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
TO SHE AYE MAYES.
MAYES NOT VOTING OKAY -- SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN AB SEVEN ONE SEVEN
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS CHILL.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE KING [inaudible]
TING HI.
NUMBER EIGHT FIVE EIGHT AB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE CHIU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING [inaudible]
TING ONLINE. TEN FILE ITEM TEN
AB NINETY FOUR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
TO CHU ÁI KENG [inaudible]
HANG ON ON NUMBER.
ELEVEN FOLLOW ELEVEN AB TWELVE
NINETY SIX CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE.
CHIU.
CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY I MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
CHIANG NOT VOTING. FIFTEEN
PHYLUM FIFTEEN AB THIRTY ONE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING WHEN THIS.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE REAVIS REVERSE I TING
[inaudible]
TING HI [inaudible]
ON EIGHTEEN FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
AB FIVE THREE THREE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GRAY.
WELL IN THIS.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN NOT [inaudible]
FOLLOWING.
EIGHTEEN MONNING AYE REAVIS.
REAVIS AYE TING TING AYE GRAY
[inaudible]
GRAY EYES [inaudible]
COURSE.
COURSE OF THE OJ I'M SORRY OKAY.
WHAT WAS THAT THEN FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
FIVE SO CHANGE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE GRAY NOT VOTING
TO OUR OKAY -- IS.
WELL CLARA.
CAMINO.
I STILL HAVE TO GET MISTER.
TO LET LET ME START FROM THE
BEGINNING AND WE'LL JUST GO
THROUGH IT. ONE FAST TIME --
MISTER TO ITEM.
ONE ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
ONE CHIU HI [inaudible]
YEAH.
HOT SPRINGS [inaudible]
FOR THAT'S AWESOME.
I HAVE EVERYBODY.
YEAH THANK YOU AND THEN WE CAN
RELATE.
REALLY THE ROLE OPEN A LITTLE
WHILE THE CHAIRS PRESENTING IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO WE LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR HER TO ADD ON
YEAH -- I
TAYLOR
[inaudible]
OKAY
--